Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Nein, nein.
Wie jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, auch diese Klänge hier auf Fritz ab 22 Uhr. Kraftwerk und Numbers, das ist die Erkennungsmelodie vom Chaos Radio. Ihr seid hier gelandet, Teil 136. Im Moment übrigens für alle Fußballgucker ganz, ganz, ganz trauriges Bild, denn da sind die Leitungen irgendwie unterbrochen nach Basel. Es geht gar nichts.
Wir waren es nicht.
Wir waren es nicht. Haben die noch einen Livestream im Netz, Frank?
Ja, der ist aber auch unterbrochen.
Okay, also es gibt gerade gar nichts. Sobald hier wieder irgendwas passiert, erzählen wir euch jetzt selbstverständlich. Wir sind heute im Teil 186. Frank ist da, den habt ihr gerade gehört. Und Huckel ist auch hier. Hallo Huckel. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir werden in den kommenden zwei Stunden uns mit einer Geschichte beschäftigen, die ihr hundertprozentig schon mal vor der Nase hattet. Es geht um den Browser, mit dem ihr durchs Netz surft. Wir werden unterschiedlichste Browser vorstellen und ein bisschen in der Geschichte der Browser graben. Vorher aber vielleicht noch eine kurze Geschichte zu einer aktuellen Nummer, die diese Woche gerade rauskam. Und zwar am Montag stellt euch vor, bei euch klingelt es an der Tür und irgendjemand sagt, guten Tag Herr Jakob Kranz, Sie sind geboren an dem und dem und dem und demsten und Sie sind religionszugehörig so und so und so und wenn ich frage, wo haben Sie das her, stand einfach so im Internet. Es gab eine Datenpanne und die Daten von mehreren hundert Einwohnern aus Deutschland, speziell auch aus Brandenburger Regionen, Potsdam, der Hardenberg, Henningstorf, standen jahrelang einfach so im Netz, Frank.
Na nicht nur hunderte, sondern hunderttausende wahrscheinlich. Also betroffen waren die Kommunen, Städte, Dörfer. Und ja, es ist eigentlich auch gleich eine schöne Einleitung ins Thema, weil es geht dann nämlich um eine webbasierte Anwendung sozusagen. Nämlich die, ja, e-Government, wie es so schön heißt. Das heißt also, irgendwelche Dienste, die ich übers Internet machen kann, nämlich irgendwie, also geplant, ist mal irgendwann Auto ummelden, Perso verlängern, alles die Sachen, die so anstehen. Und dafür war das, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, so eine Art Probelauf oder sowas, so ein Schnuppertzugang.
Probelauf gescheitert.
Probelauf gescheitert, genau. Die Firma, die das Software gemacht hat, hatte dann, ja, das Passwort, wir sind Master Passwort sozusagen, wir sind Super-User-Zugang, irgendwie durch eine blöde, dämliche Panne irgendwie im Netz und hat auch den ganzen Kommunen, die das einsetzen, die Software auch vorher nicht gesagt haben, übrigens, ihr müsst mal das Passwort ändern, das ist nur ein Standard-Passwort. Das ist also die eine Sache der Geschichte. Das andere ist natürlich, dass es überhaupt schon mal ein atrociouser Skandal ist, dass diese Datenbanken überhaupt durch diesen ganzen System überhaupt mit dem Internet verbunden sind. Und das, ja, ist insofern auch eine ganz schöne Überleitung, weil es zeigt, dass diese Einführung dieser ganzen webbasierten Dienste offensichtlich auch manchmal die Sicherheit so ein bisschen hinten dran bleibt, beziehungsweise, dass die Leute ganz prima sind und jetzt was ganz tolles super im Browser machen können und die ganze Welt kann darauf zugreifen, ohne mal zu schauen, ob nicht vielleicht sogar die ganze Welt denn auch wirklich darauf zugreift und diesen Daten gerade rumsucht und rumsurft.
Wo der Gedanke an, es funktioniert alles ganz einfach auf einer Plattform und du musst nichts anderes mehr machen, alle anderen Gedanken an Sicherheit und was steckt eigentlich dahinter, wegdringelt.
Genau, ist ja alles auf dem Server, ist ja nichts mehr auf dem Rechner, kein Sicherheitsproblem mehr, alles prima. Man kann sowas schon machen, so eine Dienste, aber dann darf man natürlich bitte nicht das Masterpasswort irgendwo auf dem Server haben und vor allem muss man auch so eine Anwendung, ich meine, das muss man ja sowieso machen eigentlich immer sein Passwort sofort ändern. Allerdings ist es aber auch wirklich fahrlässig vom Hersteller wirklich so einen extrem wichtigen Zugang, denn überhaupt mit einem Standardpasswort auszustalten. Also eigentlich müsste der gleich von Anfang an deaktiviert sein oder am besten gar nicht vorhanden sein und heute ist irgendwie die Jobcard, sogenannte Illenal-Systemen, beschlossen worden vom Bundeskabinett und da dürfte noch so einiges an Sicherheitslücken in Zukunft.
Klaas Kurses gibt wohl wieder ein Bild, es steht immer noch 1 zu 1, entspannt euch, alles cool.
Zurücklehnen. Juhu, genau, also das ist eigentlich soweit als Einleitung. Im Prinzip aktuelle Sicherheitslücke in der weltbasierten Anwendung geht ganz prima sofort direkt ins Thema Browser.
Passend dazu gibt es übrigens noch einen Song, den können wir nachher noch hören von Nicolette, die kennt ihr vielleicht von einem einigen Massive-Tech-Platt, der heißt No Government, den werden wir nachher noch hören.
Was heißt eigentlich Browser? Gibt es eigentlich einen blöden deutschen Begriff für oder einen schönen deutschen Begriff? Webseitenanzeigeprogramm?
Das ist doch die Applikation, mit der man Internetseiten ausdrucken kann, oder?
Webseitenanzeigeprogramm finde ich übrigens sehr schön.
Genau, darum geht es heute um die Webseitenanzeige, wobei man kann ja mehr machen, es ist ja nicht nur das Anzeigen, sondern man kann ja auch die Webseite wechseln, umblättern sozusagen, weiterspringen auf die nächste Webseite. Das ist die Idee von diesen Hyperlinks, wie sie richtig heißen, nämlich also einfach klicken irgendwo drauf und dann passiert was. Früher ist da einfach dann die nächste Seite aufgegangen, wo die nächste Seite wurde geladen und heutzutage kann man noch wesentlich mehr machen. Seit also dieses tolle JavaScript erfunden worden ist, da gibt es ja ein sogenanntes On-Click-Gefähe, das heißt also, dass hier wenn was klickt, heißt das noch nicht, dass jetzt tatsächlich einfach automatisch die nächste Seite geladen wird, sondern ich kann auch im Browser eine Aktion dann ausführen. Aber das sind jetzt schon fast wieder Details, wo wir so im Laufe der Sendung dann hinkommen werden.
Ich habe ein halbes Auge natürlich auf das Fußballspiel. Ihr habt zwei Augen auf die Webseiten-Anzeige-Programme. Und wenn ihr da mitreden wollt, mitdiskutieren wollt, Fragen habt oder sonstige Geschichten anmerken wollt, könnt ihr das gerne tun unter der 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110. Wie immer im Chaos-Radio freuen wir uns auch über eure Beiträge, entweder quasi am Telefon oder aber im Chat. Das geht natürlich auch, weil wir sind auch Online.
Hoffik, sind wir online? Wir können uns eine Mail schreiben zur Not an chaosradio.ccc.de und dann werden wir dazu sagen, nicht in der Mail die Mail beantworten, sondern hier im Radio beantworten. Das ist ja viel spannender, dass die anderen auch was von haben. Und... Mist, was wollte ich jetzt?
Wir waren bei Browsern.
Na, wir können ja mal anfangen hier so mit, wie das überhaupt alles zustande kam.
Was ist eigentlich ein Browser und wo kommt der her?
Und warum braucht man den überhaupt?
Genau, vor 15 Jahren hat es angefangen. Das WWW hat ja gerade Geburtstag gehabt, auch vor zwei Monaten oder so, glaube ich, war das. Das ist 15 Jahre geworden. Vor 15 Jahren hat am Kernforschungszentrum CERN der Tim Berners-Lee, ich kann diesen Namen nicht merken, die Idee gehabt, es wäre ja prima, wenn man ein Textdokument verlinken könnte, also da Links einbauen, Referenzen auf andere Seiten. Er hat das Ganze am Anfang erst mal mit Text gemacht, aber das Ganze ist ja ziemlich eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe, und dann waren die Leute total begeistert und haben gesagt, hey prima, da kann man ja auch noch Bilder mit reinnehmen.
Wobei, da ist schon noch ein Schritt davor, also das Hypertext, was sozusagen dem Ganzen zugrunde liegt, das ist ja viel älter, also da gibt es irgendwie, auf der Wikipedia-Seite, da habe ich gerade nochmal nachgeschlagen, gibt es hier schon die ersten Datierung von 1964, wo es schon darum ging, irgendwie Inhalte miteinander zu verknüpfen. Und der Tim Berners-Lee hat sozusagen den ersten Schritt gemacht, das auf die Computer dann so richtig umzumünzen, wobei das kann man auch nicht so sagen, Hypercard gab es ja schon.
Das Präsentationssystem?
Na ja, so eine Stapelverarbeitungsapplikation und da konnte man halt nicht irgendwie den Stapel so einzeln durchgehen, sondern zwischen den Karten des Stapels hin und her springen und so schon interaktive Anwendungen bauen, wo man halt zwischen diesen Stapeln mit Hypertext hin und her linken konnte. Und im Prinzip hat der Tim Berners-Lee gedacht, so als das jetzt so aufkam mit den vernetzten Computern und die Uni A kann bei Uni B mal auf den Server gucken, und gucken, was dafür Fals drauf sind, wäre es ja auch total toll, wenn man irgendwie Papers oder was auch immer für Veröffentlichung von den Unis einfach so durchbrausen könnte, sagen wir mal so. Und da hat er dann angefangen, das mal zu implementieren. Also nicht nur auf dem eigenen Rechner in irgendeinem Dokument mit Hypertexten hin und her zu springen, sondern einfach zwischen den Servern und die Dokumente von anderen Servern auch zu verlinken. Und das war eigentlich so der Aufmacher vom Web.
Genau, wir wollen auch nicht verschweigen, dass es damals noch alternative Ansätze gab, das Ganze zu machen. Einst davon war Gopher. Das hat auch mittlerweile nur noch historischen Charakter. Also auch die Idee, dass es da Server gibt, dass man da irgendwie mehr oder weniger interaktiv andere Inhalte abrufen kann. Aber letztendlich, weil es so schön und sexy ist, hat sich dann das HTTP-Protokoll durchgesetzt, Hypertext Transfer Protocol, als Disk-Protokoll, womit die ganzen Daten zum Server hin, also die Anfrage zum Server und die Daten zurück zum Browser übertragen werden.
Und dann hat er das halt gemacht. Und hat eigentlich auch, also ich weiß gar nicht, guck, ich hab hier gerade so eine Grafik offen von der Geschichte der Browsern. Also Tim Berners-Lee hat das 1991 veröffentlicht, und das hieß dann tatsächlich auch World Wide Web, und hatte glaube ich den Codenamen Nexus oder irgendwie so. Und dann hat es auch nicht lange gedauert, da kam schon der zweite, nämlich 1992, und dann 1993 ging es so richtig ab.
Das war dann schon mosaik?
Nee, da kamen erst LYNX, das waren bis dahin, also bis 1993 waren das alles konsolenbasierte Browser, also alles im Terminal, alles mit irgendwie Befehle eintippen und irgendwie noch ohne Bilder, sondern einfach nur Text.
Also bei weitem nicht so einfach wie das, was wir heute haben, du hast einfach eine Webseite, klickst irgendwo drauf, ist alles da.
Und vor allem nicht so bunt.
Ja, genau. Also klicken gab es nicht, bunt gab es nicht, und schnell gab es wahrscheinlich auch nicht. So, und dann wenig später, wo dann die Leute schon merken, aha, das ist ganz toll, aber irgendwie ist das nicht so toll ohne klicken und mit Texteingabe, da kam halt mosaik raus, das war dann sozusagen die erste Browser-Implementierung mit klicken.
Das war glaube ich auch das erste, wo ich dann angefangen habe mit einzusteigen. Das war dann so meine Uni-Zeit.
Soweit also, der ganz kurze Einblick in die Geschichte, dann machen wir nachher noch weiter, weil wir haben Dimitri am Telefon. Guten Abend, Dimitri. Ich sag mal, wieso guckst du kein Fußball? Die ganze Welt guckt Fußball und wir hatten eigentlich gedacht, wir machen so eine Nerd-Sendung mit uns selber. Du bist kein Fußball-Fan.
Doch, ich bin Fußball-Fan, aber ich habe noch ein bisschen zu arbeiten und ich habe nebenbei einen dicker Laufen.
Alles klar. War es dein Tipp, wie geht es aus? Im Moment steht es immer noch 1-1.
Also ich bin für Deutschland. Mein Tipp ist eigentlich, dass wir 3 zu 1 gewinnen.
Naja, 70. Minute bericht gleich an, müssen wir noch ein bisschen was nachlegen. Aber jetzt komm mal weg zum Fußball und eigentlich zum Thema. Wir reden heute über Browser.
Und zwar bin ich selbst Anwendungsentwickler für Browsertechnologie. Und mir ist in der Zeit immer häufiger aufgefallen, dass Anwendungen unfertig sind, beziehungsweise wirklich gravierende Fehler beinhalten. Und meine Meinung nach liegt das hauptsächlich an dem genannten Budget, der zur Verfügung gestellt wird für die ganzen Programmierer. Es fehlt einfach die Zeit, um grundlegende Sachen zu testen. Und die Kunden selbst wissen nicht wirklich, was sie wollen. Das heißt, es passieren schon Fehler beim Grunddesign.
Na das ist ja zum Beispiel tatsächlich auch, wie auch dieser eingangs erwähnten Sicherheitslücke, das Problem im Web so. Da wird ganz naiv rangegangen. Man versteht halt auch nur die Hälfte, oder wenn überhaupt die Hälfte von der Technologie, die man da benutzt. Aber das ist auch ganz normal, weil es gibt, wie wir später wahrscheinlich noch erwähnen werden, einfach Gazillionen von Features, die so in den Browsern drin sind. Und es ist einfach unmöglich, dass einer alleine überhaupt alle Features und alle Funktionen und alle Frameworks verstehen kann. Ja, das ist ganz klar, dass der Kunde sagt, ich will eine schöne Webseite mit bunt und dynamisch und klicken hier und klicken da und Autocompletion. Und dann sind halt die Entwickler dran, die müssen sich dann durch die ganzen Standards fräsen. Und wie gesagt, dann passiert es halt gerne mal, dass Autocompletion...
Aber jetzt kommt die Frage von jemandem, der keine Webseiten programmiert und sich das so ein bisschen vor... oder keine Browser entwickelt und sich das so ein bisschen vorstellt, wie so ein Lego-Baukasten, die man zusammensteckt. Im Endeffekt hast du doch jedes Bauteil einmal in der Hand und guckst, ob das funktioniert. Wieso geht es dann trotzdem unfertig raus?
Es fehlt einfach die Zeit, um das wirklich auszuprobieren, ob es wirklich funktioniert. Ich sag's mal so, man fängt irgendwo an zu entwickeln, entwickelt einen Bereich fertig, dann testen wir das Ganze, geht weiter, bastelt es irgendwo andersrum und in einem anderen Bereich, geht davon aus, dass der erste noch funktioniert. Aber man hat doch irgendwo was in der Datenbank geändert, irgendwie eine Abhängigkeit eingebaut und schon hat man einen Fehler.
Wobei, wenn wir jetzt von webbasierten Anwendungen reden, das ist ja so ein bisschen unser Schwerpunkt heute auch, da gibt es ja immer noch zwei Unsicherheitsfaktoren. Nämlich das eine ist das, was auf dem Server passiert. Und der Browser selbst.
Und die Person, die sozusagen vor dem Rechner sitzt, es ist dann noch ein dritter Faktor.
Der DAU, der dümmste anzunehmende User.
Richtig.
Aber dafür braucht man halt auch jetzt mittlerweile diese ganzen Web-Frameworks und so weiter, weil es reicht halt nicht mehr den mitgelieferten HTML-Editor vom Firefox, oder mittlerweile hat er ja keinen mehr, aber damals beim Netscape Navigator, irgendwie mit so ein simples Word, mehr oder weniger für Webseiten, das reicht halt mittlerweile nicht mehr. Und da kommen halt unglaublich viele Technologien und Komponenten zusammen, und die einfach mit den Seiteneffekten so abzuklopfen, dass man sicher sagen kann, dass alles super funktioniert, ist einfach verdammt schwer.
Aber Dimitri, da kann man ja eigentlich sagen, dass du einen ziemlich sicheren Arbeitsplatz hast. Wenn die Dinge nicht sicher sind und immer wieder zurückgehen und nachgebessert werden müssen, musst du dir auch keine Sorgen machen.
Das ist in der Tat das schöne Web-Entwickeln. Ich mache das ja auch selber. Und der Markt ist ja wirklich riesengroß, weil die meisten Leute nicht wirklich Plan haben. Und die wenigen, die so ein bisschen Plan haben, die werden auch wirklich händeringend gesucht. Also da bleibt keiner lange auf dem freien Markt, wenn er so ein bisschen Ahnung hat.
Also wenn ihr gerade eure ABI-Prüfung geschrieben habt, Mathe ist ja ein schönes Stichwort da bei dem Thema, weil auch Aufgaben rausgegangen sind, online irgendwie. Dann nehmt euch zu Herzen, was die Herren hier gesagt haben. Vielleicht werdet ihr ja die nächsten großen Programmierer und kriegt hin, dass die Sicherheitslücken endlich da mal vorbei sind.
Ja, aber ich muss doch sagen, dass die Sicherheitslücken auch auf der anderen Seite bestehen, auf der Seite Benutzer. Denn wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mich in einem Internet-Café einlogge, dann weiß ich nicht wirklich, was mit meinen Daten passiert. Das ist auch noch so eine Sache für sich.
Ja, da kommen wir vielleicht auch noch mal drauf jetzt im Laufe der Sendung. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn du da eine URL, einen Tipps in deinen Browser hast? Das können wir vielleicht gleich als nächstes dann nochmal angehen.
Also vielleicht mal so ganz generell für die Leute, die jetzt Browser einfach nur so täglich benutzen, noch mal so ein ganz kleiner Exkurs, wenn ich da oben jetzt so eine Adresse eintippe. Also ganz kurz, hattest du noch eine Frage, bevor ich jetzt hier komplett abschweife? Ja, oder?
Okay, pass mal auf, dann sag ich erstmal einen schönen Dank. Du wolltest ja sowieso noch ein bisschen arbeiten, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Weil Fußball gucken, im Radio anrufen und arbeiten nebenbei geht nicht.
Falls wir hier irgendwie einen Misserzählen rufen, ruf ich nochmal an und korrigiere uns. Ganz kurzer Exkurs, wenn ich da oben also meine URL eintippe, dann gibt es einen sogenannten HTTP GET wird dann erzeugt. Das ist also ein Aufruf, sagt man ein Protokoll. Das heißt also, da fängt dann mein Browser, kommuniziert dann, baut eine Verbindung auf und kommuniziert dann mit dem Server, mit dem Web-Server und sagt dann hier ist jemand, nämlich ein Browser und der hätte gern die und die Webseite abgerufen.
Und der Browser kann schon sehen, was das, der Web-Server kann schon sehen, was das für ein Browser ist?
Der Web-Server kann dann schon sehen, was das für ein Browser ist in der Regel. Wenn ich das mit übertrage, also wenn ich es nicht explizit sperre, das ist so, dass die Browser da eine Kennung übertragen. Dann kann also der Web-Server, könnte dann schon theoretisch sehen, das wird auch gelegentlich gemacht, dass dann also schon auf dem Web-Server entschieden wird, okay, das ist möglicherweise ein Mobilgerät, also zum Beispiel ein Handy, eine Browser, da hat er so ein ganz kleines Display, dem liefer ich jetzt mal eine vereinfachte Version aus. Oder das ist irgendwie der Internet Explorer 5.34278 und der hat einen total blöden Bug an der linken Ecke ganz hinten.
Das heißt, alle wichchen Informationen machen die linke Ecke ganz hinten.
Genau, dann kann er ja entsprechend schon reagieren oder sagen, der ist halt da irgendwie kaputt oder so. Das macht man aber heutzutage eher nicht mehr, sondern das wird dann schon quasi im Browser selbst entschieden. Das heißt also der Web-Server liefert dann einfach eine Webseite aus, die für alle Browser irgendwie geht und für die paar speziellen Macken ist dann da im HTML Code nochmal was eingebaut, eine Weiche.
Aber auf jeden Fall gibt die URL ein, dann baut der Browser halt eine Verbindung zu dem gewünschten Server auf, meinetwegen ccde. Dann sagt der Server, ah, alles klar, du willst jetzt also die Startseite haben und dann sammelt er die Startseite zusammen. Wie auch immer das passiert, ob es jetzt dynamisch zusammengebaut wird oder einfach eine Datei da rumliegt und schickt dir den Browser zurück. Der Browser guckt sich die an und wenn er damit was anfangen kann, also sprich, wenn das so HTML ist, was er verstehen kann, dann zeigt er das dementsprechend an und baut da sozusagen einen Layout zusammen aus diesen Buchstaben, die da angeflogen kommen vom Web-Server.
Genau, wobei das mal eben was zusammenbauen ist ja schon mal wieder ein hochkomplexer Vorgang. Es fängt erstmal an, dass dieser sogenannte HTML, das ist also der sogenannte Quellcode von Webseiten, wenn man da von Code reden kann. Das ist eine Auszeichnungssprache. Genau, eine Markup Language heißt das, also HTML, für Hypertext Markup Language. Und das besteht im Wesentlichen aus spitzen Klammern. Da sind die sogenannten Tags, die da drin stehen. Da steht zum Beispiel, das ist eine Überschrift und das ist irgendwie eine Unterüberschrift. Oder das soll jetzt kursiv dargestellt werden. Oder hier ist jetzt eine Tabelle und das sind die einzelnen Elemente. So baut man also so eine HTML-Seite auf. Das kann man ganz prima sehen, wenn man im Browser irgendwie Quellcode anzeigen. Kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle, aber macht man dann doch nicht so häufig. Ist manchmal ganz spannend, wenn man mal ein bisschen sich anschauen will, was die Webseite eigentlich so tut oder wo irgendwelche Formulardaten hingeschickt werden, dann ist es immer ganz gut, einfach mal einen Blick in den Quellcode der Seite einzuwerfen. So, und da sind dann verschiedene Referenzen drin, auf zum Beispiel Bilder oder Grafiken oder auch noch, es kann auch drin sein, Java-Skript, also quasi interaktive Elemente auf der Seite oder Programmausführungsteile.
Da kommen wir, glaube ich, auch noch mal später zu. Also ich meine, die Sache, die er jetzt ja noch am Schluss gesagt hatte, war ja, wenn ich im Internet-Café Formulardaten eingehe, weiß ich ja gar nicht, was damit passiert. Was damit passiert ist letztendlich, die werden halt abgeschickt. In der Regel weiß man, also kann man einfach nicht definitiv sagen, wohin sie geschickt würden.
Formulardaten heißt, um es einfach zu erzählen, du sitzt irgendwo, musst deine GMX oder deine was auch immer Adresse angeben, und hast ein kleines Fensterchen, wo du Daten eingeben musst.
Genau, und ein normaler User hat halt sozusagen diesen Browser vor sich und dem Vertrauter auch, in dem steckt er die Daten rein und geht einfach davon aus, dass alles passiert, aber er weiß in der Regel eigentlich nicht, was damit passiert. Weil das kann man auch relativ schwer sagen, weil da eben auf dem Weg vom Browser zum Web-Server und wieder zurück einfach noch so ein paar Schritte dazwischen sind.
Nämlich das ganze Internet.
Das ganze Internet. Und was da so dazwischen passiert, kann man einfach nicht sagen. Zum einen könnte jetzt der Internet-Café-Betreiber einfach schon direkt sagen, ok, alles, was jetzt durch mein DSL-Konto geht, das speichere ich mir zum Beispiel immer weg. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendjemand unverschlüsselt sich einloggt auf seinem Web-Server und seinen Web-Blog updated oder so weiter, dann hat der Internet-Café-Provider das vielleicht sogar schon direkt auf der Platte.
Und demnächst habt ihr noch weitere Reiseberichte an eurem Blog. Im glücklichsten Fall.
So, das ist dann schon Schritt eins. Also es geht direkt da los und das geht halt auf jeder, auf jedem Schritt zu dem Ziel-Web-Server so weiter. Also jeder, der dazwischen hängen kann sozusagen erstmal mit lauschen und Sachen manipulieren. Der kann auch auf dem Weg zum Ziel-Web-Server einfach die Daten schon umpacken und was ganz anderes dann am Ende rauskommen lassen. Also das ist wirklich, kann man nicht sagen.
Also was Huckel da eigentlich sagen will, ist, wenn ihr in einem Internet-Café in Mogadischu oder wo auch immer sitzt und dringend Online-Banking machen, dann überlegt euch dreimal, ob es wirklich wichtig ist oder ob ihr nicht vielleicht warten könnt, bis ihr wieder zu Hause seid. Nicht, dass man da... Moment, es flüstert gerade Tor auf meinen Ohr. Tor für Deutschland, 2 zu 1. Schweinsteiger klatsche die Hände, das heißt Schweini hat noch ein Tor geschossen. 2-1 in der 76. 78. Minute. Zwölf Minuten noch, wenn wir mal durchhalten. Okay, das wollte ich gar nicht weiter ausfinden, aber das ist die Geschichte, die du eigentlich erzählen wolltest. Wenn man irgendwo sitzt und ich weiß, was dahinter dem Rechner hängt, dann überlegt euch genau, welche Daten ihr da reinhackt, weil wer weiß, wer die kriegt.
Genau, und selbst wenn die Daten verschlüsselt werden, das gibt es ja sogenannte HTTPS, das erkennt ihr also an dem S hinter dem HTTPS. Und meistens ist auch so...
Du musst mich korrigieren, mir ist Miroslav Klose per Kopftor.
Kleiner Schlüssel, kleines Schlüsselsymbol unten. Das heißt also verschlüsselte Verbindung, alles gut. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass der Rechner, auf dem ihr im Internet-Café sitzt, auf dem ihr arbeitet, dass der nicht vielleicht auch die ganzen Tastatureingaben mitprotokolliert. Also selbst wenn auf der Leitung, die man mithören kann, ist natürlich keine Garantie, dass im Internet-Café nicht der ganze Computer irgendwie verwandt ist.
Keylogger-Stichwort.
Genau. Das auch noch so als kleiner Sicherheitshinweis fürs Webklicken unterwegs.
Okay, aber wir waren eigentlich so beim Quellcode und was macht der Browser mit dem Server und der Server mit dem Browser?
Genau, wir können ja einfach mal jetzt weitermachen. Wir haben jetzt den Request an den Server geschickt. Wir gehen mal davon aus, dass alles einfach so funktioniert hat, wie wir das erwarten wollen, kommt so eine Webseite zurück. Was der Browser dann macht, ist halt, also man kann sich das schon als Parallele zu Indesign vorstellen. Indesign ist ein Programm von Adobe zum Layouten von Dokumenten. Das ist ja auch irgendwie intern da natürlich strukturierter Inhalt. Da haben die auch ihre interne Auszeichnungssprache, um dem User auf dem Bildschirm so ein Dokument zu manifestieren. Beim Browser ist ganz ähnlich, da kommt halt irgendwelcher Code an oder Mark-Absprache und der muss jetzt ein Layout daraus zusammenbauen, damit irgendwie runde Ecken, Schatten, Verläufe und der ganze Kram an richtige Ort und Stelle sind. Der hat erstmal eine ganze Menge zu tun, nämlich genau das gleiche wie so ein Layout-Programm. Der muss irgendwie mit Texten gut umgehen können, Umbrüche. Der muss irgendwie mit Positionierungen umgehen können, mit grafischen Elementen und muss das da alles so zusammenbauen. Das ist ein relativ teurer Prozess, sagt man so in der Computerwelt. Also das heißt, es braucht relativ viel Rechenzeit, tatsächlich auch alle Elemente so ineinander zu stecken. In der Regel sind einfach verdammt viele auf so einer Webseite drauf. Also in der Regel hat man ja schon so eine Webseite mit wahrscheinlich ein paar tausend Texten am Ende bei so einer Corporate-Webseite drauf.
Ja, und je mehr Grafik involviert ist, desto schwieriger wird es wahrscheinlich nochmal, wenn da bestimmte Vorgaben gemacht werden, wie der Text umzufliessen, also umzufliessen hat um die Grafikelemente, wenn man vielleicht noch verschiedene Schriftarten benutzt.
Also es geht halt eigentlich so los, du kriegst die Seite und dann baut er erstmal die Seite zusammen, also die Struktur. So, wenn er das geschafft hat, dann kommt das Style-Sheet. So, und dann sagt man jetzt, ok, dieses Element P soll jetzt mal roten Hintergrund haben und soll links positioniert sein. Das Element Überschrift 3 soll hier sein und so weiter und so fort. Also man gibt dann sozusagen diesen ganzen Elementen nochmal, ja, wie sagt man...
Grafischen Anstrich oder so?
Grafischen Anstrich, genau, das heißt, das ist so der zweite Schritt des Renderns. Erst mal dann den Style noch drüber rendern. So und dann geht es halt weiter mit Images laden. Das heißt, auf der Seite sind irgendwie noch Images, macht da glaube ich sogar parallel und lädt dann noch die Images dazu. Die kommen natürlich auch noch in die Position. Und während er dann die Images lädt, bricht ja dann das Layout gegebenenfalls auch nochmal um, ja. Also man sieht ja dann, wenn so eine Seite sich aufbaut, da wubbelt es und wabbelt es ja gegebenenfalls hier und da mal.
Also das alles da ist groß hingehört?
Genau und wie gesagt, dieser Prozess, das alles zusammenzubauen, ist schon relativ aufwendig. Und das ist dann eben auch noch nicht der letzte Schritt, dann kommt vielleicht noch JavaScript dazu. Das heißt, irgendwie die Seite ist fertig geladen und dann, wenn die Seite fertig geladen ist, dann wird ein JavaScript ausgeführt. Und dieses JavaScript geht dann über die ganze Seite rüber und hängt zum Beispiel an alle Links noch ein JavaScript-Schnipsel ran, dass wenn du raufklickst, irgendwie ein Pop-Up aufgeht und sagt, du hast jetzt diesen Link geklickt, irgendwelche Sachen. Das heißt, dieser Baum, der da gebaut wird, diese Struktur wird dann nochmal weiter aufgebläht. Und irgendwann, wenn dann alles geladen und alles ausgeführt ist, hat man dann so seine Seite fertig.
Das JavaScript, die fangen wir mal noch weiter vorne an, wir waren nämlich bei, oder erstmal Luft holen?
Erstmal Luft holen, dann fahren wir nach Vorschlag, weil wir haben noch etwa anderthalb Minuten, dann sind wir sowieso in den Nachrichten, wir sind ja gerade dabei, dass die Seite fertig aufgebaut wurde.
Genau, dann merken wir uns mal irgendwie Style-Sheets und JavaScript.
Der Browser baut die Seite zusammen, hat die JavaScripts dran gehängt, welcher Browser das wie zusammenbaut, welcher Browser das kann oder nicht kann, das klären wir gleich im Chaosradio. 2.1 steht es immer noch für Deutschland. Wir haben gleich die Nachrichten für euch mit den aktuellen Entwicklungen. Und vorher ein Stückchen Musik von Nicolette. Und eben gerade reden wir noch drüber wie die Türkei das letzte Spiel, wo sie 0-2 zurücklagen, mit 3-2 dann auch gewonnen haben. Kurz vor Schluss, Deutschland führte 2-1 und jetzt gerade gab es den Ausgleich in der 85. Minute. Sammy schießt den Ausgleich, damit steht es wieder 2-2 und wir segeln volle Kanone auf der Verlängerung zu. Mehr gleich in den Nachrichten. Die Frau, die hier singt, kennt ihr sicherlich noch von einigen Massive-Tech-Platten. Hab ich dir gerade erzählt? Nee, so eine Hacke hackt dann doch nicht. Na wenn ja, könnt ihr das irgendwie auf mich schieben. Nicolette heißt sie, No Government haben wir gehört im Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Fritz präsentiert das Bekewiesen Open Air in Klein-Machno. Das Woodstock vor den Toren Potsdam. Mit Calcha Candela. Und noch so einigen anderen. Das Bekewiesen Open Air. Kommenden Samstag. Auf der Bekewiese in Kleinmachno. Karten gibt's überall wo's Karten gibt und mehr Infos. Das Bekewiesen Open Air.
Und das war zweieinhalb elf.
Nachricht mit Matthias Tachau.
Bei der Fußball-Europameisterschaft spielt die deutsche Nationalmannschaft gerade gegen die Türkei. Das DFB-Team kämpft in Basel um den Einzug ins Finale. 200 Minuten vor regulärem Ende steht es 2 zu 2 unentschieden. Die Tore für die Türkei schossen Urgo und Semih sowie Schweinsteiger und Klose für Deutschland. Auf Deutschlands größter Fan-Meile in Berlin wurden eine Stunde vor Spielbeginn die Eingänge geschlossen. Etwa 500.000 Fans feiern laut einer Sprecherin rund ums Brandenburger Tor. Der Streit um die Wiederholung der Mathe-Prüfung für den mittleren Schulabschluss an Berliner Schulen geht weiter. Bildungssenator Zöllner legte inzwischen ein Gutachten eines Wissenschaftlers der Humboldt-Universität vor, wonach die Aufgaben nicht schwerer waren als bei der ersten Klausur. Der Vorsitzende des Landeselternausschusses Schindler widersprach dem Gutachten und berief sich auf andere Experten. Unabhängig vom Streit hat Zöllner die Kriterien für das Bestehen der Klausur herabgesetzt. Jetzt bestehen die Schüler die Klausur schon mit 45, statt mit 50 Prozent der Punkten. Die Kluft zwischen Arm und Reich in Deutschland hat sich weiter vertieft. Das geht aus dem Armuts- und Reichtumsbericht der Bundesregierung hervor. Zuletzt waren 13 Prozent der Bundesbürger arm, das ist jede achte Deutsche. Durch staatliche Leistungen wie Arbeitslosen oder Kindergeld sei die Armutsquote aber von 26 auf 13 Prozent halbiert worden, sagte Vize-Regierungsprecher Steg. Das zeige, dass der deutsche Sozialstaat wirke. Gewerkschaften und Sozialverbände reagierten mit scharfer Kritik und forderten höherer Hartz-IV-Regelsätze und Mindestlöhne. Die Strafrechtsverschärfung für Neonazi-Kundgebungen ist verfassungsgemäß. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in einem Grundsatzurteil entschieden. Damit bestätigten die Richter das Verbot einer Kundgebung zum Todestag des Hitler-Stellvertreters Hess im bayerischen Wunsiedel. Das dortige Landratsamt hatte 2005 eine geplante Veranstaltung verboten und sich dabei auf den verschärften Volksverletzungsparagrafen bezogen. Danach macht sich strafbar, wer öffentlich die Würde der NS-Opfer verletzt oder nationalsozialistische Gewalt und Willkürherrschaft billigt. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Neurupin und Angermünde 19, Cottbus 20, Frankfurt 21, Potsdam 3 zu 2 für Deutschland, Tor gerade nebenbei, in der 89.
Oh wir drücken die Daumen, so Wetter mach weiter.
Dolzki, ich hab den Fernseher im Rücken, ich kann das nicht sehen. In Potsdam und Wittenberge 22 Grad und in Berlin auch 22 Grad. In Richtung Lausitz gibt es heute Nacht noch gewittrigen Regen, der zieht später dann gegen Osten ab. Die Temperaturen liegen nachts zwischen 12 und 16 Grad, morgen ist es meist heiter, später kommen von Westen wieder mehr Wolken dazu. Es bleibt aber meist trocken bei maximal 26 Grad. A2 Richtung Magdeburg, zwischen Wollin und Ciesa steht ein kaputtes Auto, der Standstreifen hier ist dicht. A115, Abus statt auswärts. Hinter der spanischen Allee wird auf der rechten Spur gebaut, hier kann es immer wieder zu Stau kommen. Ok, hatten wir schon. Ich habe noch eine Meldung vom Stadtverkehr Berlin. Wegen der Fan-Meile ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Brandenburger Tor und Großem Stern gesperrt.
Das war Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr mit Matthias Sachau. Zack und da ist das Bild weg. Nein, er ist wieder da. Kurze Nachspielzeit, wir bleiben dran. Auf jeden Fall für euch. 3 zu 2 für Deutschland in den letzten Sekunden vom EM-Halbfinale.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und bei einem Radio 91, 9? Dann Fritz rund um Welt sich.
Einen wunderbaren guten Abend, wir haben das Chaos Radio Teil 136. Huckel ist hier, Frank ist hier vom CTC, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden heute über Web-Browser, aber natürlich soll noch so viel Zeit sein, dass wir hier die letzten Sekunden vom Fußballspiel mitnehmen. Ich denke, das kann man schon mal machen, die spielen noch wenige Sekunden nach. Bevor wir weiter über Web-Browser reden, gehen wir mal den O-Ton rein in der Ausreportage vom Spiel. Anderthalb Minuten noch.
Die erste Runde kommt für den angeschlagenen Kazim.
Und Jürgen Löw bringt Marcel Jansen für Miroslav Klose.
Den Torschützen zum 2 zu 1.
Für's Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal. Das Finale ist nah. Noch eine Minute in Basel. Schweinsteiger Bordolsky auf sich alleine gestellt. Foul an Mehmet Topal aber Vorteil. Jetzt Freistoß Türkei.
Thürmer.
Thürmer gegen Balak. Und Foul des Kapitäts.
Noch einmal eine gefährliche Distanz für Lehmann. 30 Sekunden vor dem Ende der Nachspielzeit.
Knisternde Spannung unter dem Gewitterhimmel von Basel. Ich höre übrigens immer noch Fritz, Chaosradio, die letzten Sekunden vom Spiel Deutschland gegen Türkei. Original Ton aus Basel auf dem Stadion. Ihre Gebete sind oft erhöht worden.
Nachspielzeit ist jetzt abgelaufen.
Dieser Freistoß wird mit Sicherheit noch ausgeführt. Ey, wenn die jetzt in Ausreich schießen. Thürmer oder Alton Topp.
Das müsste es gewesen sein.
Ball geht übers Tor. Mit dem Thürmer, Boussaka schaut auf die Uhr.
Lehmann lässt sich Zeit beim Abstoß. Tschüss!
So, Abpfiff, das war der O-Ton von Belaredi aus dem Stadion in Basel. Deutschland besiegt die Türkei mit 3 zu 2 und damit ist jetzt hier Finale, Finale, Schlang, Schlang, Schlang. Und wir wünschen euch eine großartige Party und machen jetzt gleich weiter im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritztal 136 Mittwoch 25. Juni 2008. Huckel ist hier, Frank ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden über Web-Browser, sind vor den Nachrichten stehen geblieben, wie der Browser eigentlich eine Webseite zusammengebaut, zusammenbaut mit der Baumstruktur, mit den einzelnen Java-Applikationen und den Images, die reingehen und da werden wir jetzt gleich weiter ansitzen.
Und zwar machen wir noch mal ein bisschen mit den Browsern als solche weiter, weil am Anfang war ja noch gar kein Style-Sheet und noch kein Java-Skript.
Am Anfang war das HTML.
Genau, ganz plain vanilla HTML, wie man jetzt so in Neussprech sagt.
Plain vanilla heißt es schon.
Und zwar ging es dann halt los. Mosaik hat man als Letzten genannt. So und dann, das erfreute sich auch erstaunlicher Popularität. So, das haben auch echt eine ganze Menge Leute benutzt und irgendwie immer mehr Leute haben festgestellt, das Web, das ist eine total tolle Idee. So und dann hat es auch nicht lange auf sich warten lassen, dass aus diesem Mosaik, den ich das jetzt hier richtig auf meiner Grafik sehe, der Netscape Navigator direkt auch schon entstand. Und den kennen ja eigentlich wahrscheinlich noch viele von uns. Also ich kann mich erinnern, das war mein erster Browser, weil ich bin ein bisschen später eingestiegen, aber ich hatte einen Netscape Navigator.
Quasi so die Mutter der Browser, mit denen wir heutzutage eigentlich auch arbeiten.
Genau, da kommt so ein großes N her, mit dem dunkelgrünen Hintergrund, glaube ich, so türkis-dunkelgrün und ein paar Sternchen drum, glaube ich, noch.
Genau, also Netscape war dann schon so in meinem, auch schon damals, computeraffinen Befinden irgendwie schon so ein bisschen populär Kultur. Also jeder, der irgendwie im Internet war, und das waren noch nicht viele, die hatten irgendwie alle schon so einen Netscape Navigator, weil der war doch eine Ecke tollere als das Mosaik. Mosaik war halt schon sehr einfach gestrickt noch. Und Netscape Navigator hatte halt, weiß nicht, was da die ersten Features waren, aber so Bookmarks kamen ja auch irgendwie relativ schnell, also dass man so Lesezeichen ablegen konnte. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Mosaik das selber hatte, aber irgendwie hat er sich gut benutzen lassen. Das war so eine Applikation, die man schon gerne gestartet hat und hat einfach gut funktioniert.
Wobei Geschwindigkeit damals noch gar nicht so der Punkt war, weil dann auch die meisten über Modem irgendwie reingegangen sind. Da war dann die eigentliche Datenübertragung, hat dann meistens sowieso viel länger gedauert, als eine eigentliche Seite aufzubauen. Heute ist das mittlerweile was anderes, wenn wir fetten Internetzugang haben, aber die Browser vielleicht auf einem bisschen betagten PC gar nicht mehr hinterher kommen, die ganzen Seiten darzustellen.
Genau. So und dann wenig später, also ich sehe das hier gerade, da sprudelten schon diverse Browser hinterher, irgendwie Webrunner, Slipknot, W3M, Omniweb. Omniweb war auch ganz früh dabei, 1995. Also 1995 war ich auch genau tatsächlich dann das erste Mal online. Und dann kam der nächste große Contender, das nächste Schwergewicht in der Browserlandschaft, nämlich der Internet Explorer.
Da hat Microsoft dann mal gesagt, hey, es gibt ja da so ein Internet da draußen.
Ja und der hat am Anfang die Mosaik Engine benutzt, also die haben angefangen mit Mosaik, stand auch eine ganze Zeit lang irgendwie in dem About-Text drin. So und dann ging es halt los. Dann gab es so Internet Explorer und Netscape Navigator, so auf den Computern, also viel was anderes hat man da. Also ich habe da nichts anderes mehr gesehen. Und dann läutete sich so die Ehre ein, der legendäre Browser-Krieg. Der legendäre Browser-Krieg. Genau und das lief halt so. Netscape hatte die absolute Marktführerschaft, also die waren wirklich auf jedem PC und Internet Explorer war am Anfang halt so eher so ein Nischenprodukt. Und dann ging es halt los, dass Microsoft da, aber Netscape sich relativ schnell immer neue Versionen geliefert haben. Das war immer so ein Versionsschlagabtausch. Netscape 2 kam raus, kurz darauf Internet Explorer 2. Netscape Navigator 3, Internet Explorer 3. Also es ging wirklich Schlag auf Schlag. Und die haben dann auch immer Features, Features, Features hinzugefügt. Und da ging es dann auch so das erste Mal los, dass einfach von Version zu Version die Browser irgendwie instabiler waren, weil die Leute halt, also weil die Firmen mehr auf Features gesetzt haben, als Verkaufsargument oder als Argument die Browser zu vertreiben. Und durch diese hohe Geschwindigkeit des Entwicklens wurden die halt immer instabiler und wackeliger.
Das, was Dimitri auch gerade erzählt hat am Telefon unter 0371 77 97 1 10, wenn ihr mit telefonieren wollt, gerne mit anrufen wollt, dass er als Entwickler von solchen Produkten, wenn man es so einfach nennen kann, auch sagen kann, dass die zur Hälfte unfertig rausgehen, weil einfach gar keine Zeit und kein Geld da ist, das zu machen.
Genau. Ja, und dann gibt es halt mehrere Aspekte bei diesem legendären Browser-Krieg, warum man das überhaupt kriegt. Und zwar, der Internet Explorer war dann auch tatsächlich irgendwann einfach mal ebenbürtig mit dem Netscape-Navigator und dann hat Microsoft angefangen, so ein bisschen fiese Matenten zu machen. Also es war nicht so richtig unfair. Sie haben halt irgendwie gesagt, okay, Internet Explorer ist bei unserem Windows einfach standardmäßig installiert. Dann haben sie irgendwie mit CompuSurf und AOL, das sind vielleicht auch noch so Firmen, die man so im Ohr hat, haben sie gesagt, okay, wenn ihr eure Software zum Online gehen überhaupt vertreibt, dann bundelt mal den Internet Explorer gleich mit dazu. Das heißt, sie haben einfach dafür gesorgt, dass der Browser schon überall einfach da ist, wohingegen man den Netscape-Navigator in den meisten Fällen noch runterladen musste.
Wie war denn das mit dem Geschäftsmodell? Gab es nicht sogar auch mal so eine Kaufversion davon, eine Bezahlversion?
Es gab Browser zum Kaufen, aber ich habe noch mal nachgelesen, der Hauptmarktwert von Browser-Software hat sich dadurch ermittelt, dass der Browser, der die größte Install-Base hat, also die meisten downloaden Versionen, hat halt auch so eine gewisse Macht. Weil du konntest halt in deinem Browser, ihr erinnert euch bestimmt alle, oben war, wenn du den runtergeladen hast, gleich schon irgendwie Bookmarks auf Yahoo, auf Deutsche Bank, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Firmen. Und das haben die Firmen bezahlt, den Browser-Herstellern. Also damit sie defaultmäßig oben in der Bookmark-Leiste drin waren, haben die Geld bezahlt. Und natürlich, wenn du irgendwie 95 Prozent des Marktes hast, dann kommen sie halt alle zu dir und du kannst dann den Preis bestimmen.
Ein cleveres Kerlchen, dieser Bill Gates.
Und das zweite war halt die Suchmaschinen. Die wollten halt auch benutzt werden und Werbung schalten und so weiter. Und Yahoo! gerade war ja noch ein riesen Portal und Alta Vista. Die hatten so richtig, hier kauf dein Auto, hier bring dein Hund zum Friseur auf ihrer Suchmaschinenseite. Also die Suche stand da noch ein bisschen im Hintergrund. Na ja, kann man schon so sagen, ein bisschen. Und die haben wiederum auch den Browsern Geld bezahlt, dafür, dass sie die default Suche waren. Also wenn du den Browser aufgemacht hast, das gleich in der Yahoo-Seite aufpoppt. Und das war sozusagen das Geschäftsmodell. Und darum haben die sich beide so bekriegt. Die wollten halt irgendwie Features, Features, Features. Die wollten auf den meisten Rechnern sein. Und damit halt dieses Geld aus den Vermarktungsgeschichten bekommen.
Wie hat denn der Netscape-Navigator da reagiert, als Microsoft 95% aller AOL-Kunden schon mal partout im Sack hatte?
Na das war eben dieses legendäre Antitrust-Verfahren, was daraus resultierte, wo der Netscape halt gegen diese Marketing oder Vermarktungsmethoden geklagt hat. Und im Prinzip auch zu Recht. Die andere Seite der Medaille ist halt, dass der Internet Explorer einfach zu der Zeit der bessere Browser war. Und zwar deutlich. Netscape hatte halt, es war eine kleine Firma, die hatten nicht so viele Entwickler, die haben halt irgendwie mit hoher Geschwindigkeit Features da reingekodet, die Stabilität ging in den Keller. Und sie haben die damals existierenden Web-Standards nicht so richtig gern gehabt. Also der Internet Explorer war tatsächlich der erste Browser der CSS, also diese Cascading Style Sheets implementiert hat. Und das war beim Netscape nicht drin. Und dadurch haben so mehr und mehr Leute erstens empfunden, dass der Internet Explorer stabiler war, schneller war, und der hatte einfach auch die cooleren Features. Also du konntest mehr mit deinen Webseiten machen, wenn du Internet Explorer benutzt hast. Und diese Geräte gingen dann immer weiter auseinander. Also die Netscape-Jungs haben dann immer mehr Markt verloren, die haben irgendwie immer instabilere Versionen produziert. Ihre Features, die sie drin hatten oder implementiert haben, waren einfach nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand, nicht am Puls der Zeit. Und dann haben sie einfach das Rennen sozusagen verloren. Und da diese Marketing-Geschichten führen, war natürlich auch ein Teil davon. Dieser Antitrust-Case und diese fiesen Martenten von Microsoft. Aber wie gesagt, am Ende muss man sagen, war der Internet Explorer einfach besser. Und heutzutage beschwert sich auch keiner mehr, dass auf seinem Mac OS ein Safari ist, auf seinem Linux ein Conqueror und auf dem Windows ein Internet Explorer. Also das ist mittlerweile auch total normal. Und das ist glaube ich so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung eigentlich immer so dieser Browser-Krieg. Ja, die haben dann einfach den Internet Explorer defaultmäßig mitgeliefert und dann hat der Netscape keine Chance mehr. Hätte Netscape den schickeren Browser gehabt, hätten sie sich trotzdem den alle runtergeladen.
Wobei heute wissen wir ja auch alle, wie man seine Bookmarks irgendwie wegklickt und dass man irgendwie, selbst wenn es da irgendwie vorgeschlagen ist, dass man auch woanders sein Konto öffnen kann oder dass es noch eine andere Suchmaschine gibt. Wahrscheinlich haben sich einfach auch die Geschäftsmodelle ein bisschen verändert, dass es also nicht mehr so wichtig ist und die Leute wissen mittlerweile auch um die Alternativen.
Naja, also, ja, Quatsch hier. Firefox verdient richtig fett viel Kohle, dadurch dass sie die Google Ads, die Versuche drin haben.
Da sind wir ja auch bei einem der, wenn ich wieder mal kurz reingerätschen dann, bei einem der Aufhänger für die Sendung heute, denn der Firefox 3 ist ja vor wenigen Tagen, letzte Woche glaube ich gerade erschienen. Heute kam das Update, weil nachdem der Firefox draußen war, sofort die Meldung kam, da gibt es Sicherheitslücken ohne Ende, wartet man auf das Patch. Das kam heute und da werden wir sich auch noch drauf eingehen.
Können wir direkt jetzt gleich weitergehen?
Weil wir hatten Netzgehr, wir hatten Internet Explorer und glaube nach Safari, nach Safari bei macOS, ist der Firefox wohl am weitesten verbreitetste.
Genau, es gibt ja noch ein paar, wir nennen das Randgruppenbrowser. Das sind dann so ein paar ganz, wobei Opera ist ja fast ein bisschen fies als Randgruppenbrowser. Das ist noch ein ziemlich großer Player, nicht groß, aber ein wichtiger Player auch schon noch, weil er sich schon seit ein paar Jahren Namen gemacht hat für sehr kleine, effiziente Browser.
Opera läuft zum Beispiel wunderbar auf einem Handy.
Genau, das sind gerade auf Mobilgeräten, sind die, glaube ich, Marktführer wahrscheinlich nicht, aber schon ziemlich gut vertreten. Wobei ich auch gar nicht weiß, wie deren Modell aussieht, weil es gibt ja auch für die, zumindest für die Symbian oder die Java ist das, gibt es eine kostenfreie Version, die ich mir runterladen kann. Wahrscheinlich ist es aber dann kostenpflichtig, wenn es der Hersteller vorinstallieren will auf dem Gerät als Browser.
Ja, die verdienen an Lizenzen. Aber so dann, da werden wir dann mal weitermachen nach, der Krieg war vorbei, Microsoft stand als strahlender Sieger da, und dann begann halt die Umkehrung des Marktanteils, also die hatten dann mehr Marktanteil als Netscape jemals hatte. Die hatten dann am Ende im Peak, glaube ich, 95% Marktanteil, Netscape hatte im Peak 86%. Also die waren einfach überall, die waren auf Mac, die waren auf Windows, die waren überall installiert. Das Netscape-Projekt war dann eigentlich so mehr oder weniger tot, und in der letzten Verzweiflungstat haben sie dann ihren Browser open source gemacht. Also sie haben gesagt, hier, pass auf, wir geben jetzt erstmal auf, oder wir haben verloren, hier ist unser Code, vielleicht kann ja der eine oder andere noch was damit machen. So, und dann ging es halt los, Internet Explorer war einfach immer präsent, und Mozilla, genau Mozilla hieß dann das Projekt, was daraus resultierte aus Netscape, und die siechten ewig vor sich hin. Also die sind ewig nicht aus diesem Netscape-Loch sozusagen rausgekommen, haben ewig nicht den Internet Explorer aufgeholt, die hatten eine riesenfette Codebase, das war wirklich einfach scheußliche Software, langsam, buggy. Also ich weiß nicht, du hast doch bestimmt auch Mozilla irgendwie mal so eine Zeit lang probiert und dann irgendwie...
Ja, immer mehr, weil der Internet Explorer eigentlich immer suspekt, muss ich sagen.
Ja, genau, als Nerds hat man dann irgendwie gedacht, ja, Open-Source-Projekt und so, das muss man ja schon unterstützen, Microsoft ist evil, aber am Ende war es, war trotzdem der Internet Explorer einfach der bessere Browser. Sie waren halt auch lange wirklich darum bemüht, so was wie CSS1 zu implementieren, die hatten ja auch VB-Script im Browser, so als eine der ersten, das ging ja dann auch so langsam los, und ja, Mozilla immer noch rumgesiegt. Und dann irgendwann haben sie halt da auch nochmal einen Cut gemacht, irgendwie die Hälfte weggeschmissen und gesagt, so jetzt machen wir ein neues Projekt, das heißt Firefox, wir nehmen jetzt nur noch ganz wenig von diesem Mozilla Code und specken das einfach mal alles ab, weil früher war ja in Mozilla ein Mailclient drin.
Genau, ein HTML-Editor.
Ein HTML-Editor, ein Newsreader für Newsgroups. Und das war halt eine riesen Applikation.
Adressbuch natürlich auch.
Adressbuch, genau, E-Mailclient, den ganzen Kram. Mozilla war eigentlich so die erste...
War wie so ein Office-Paket fürs Web.
Genau, das war schon so eine große Applikation, so schwer und behäbig. Und Firefox war dann eben so der Schnitt mit dieser Methode, einfach wir machen jetzt nur einen Browser und der soll gut sein und schnell und leicht.
Ich glaube, so in der Zeit, wo Mozilla vor sich hin dümpelte, habe ich, glaube ich, Opera benutzt. Das war so der Zeitpunkt.
Das war so die Alternative dazu eigentlich.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, Opera hatte ich auch immer mal wieder auf dem Radar. Das gab es eine Zeit lang nur gegen Geld, ne?
Ja, oder eine werbefinanzierte Version, glaube ich. Aber dann gab es halt irgendwie auch aus dem Internet irgendwelche Normanden.
Aber so richtig warm geworden bin ich mit dem auch nicht.
Na, Opera hatte eine Weile das, was Mozilla später dann dazuschub, nämlich dieses Tab-Browsing. Also, dass du nicht unterschiedliche Websiten eigentlich aufmachen musst und zwischen den Seiten hin und her prökelst, sondern alle diese Seiten als Tabs auf deinem Desk verpressen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir also schon mal so ein paar Browser genannt. Wir haben jetzt den Internet Explorer, wir haben den Firefox, der irgendwie in der ersten Version zwar schon deutlich besser als Mozilla war, aber immer noch kränkelter, so instabil war und Probleme hatte. Dann, ja, gucken wir mal hier, wann kam denn hier Firefox überhaupt auf den Schirm?
2003, so was?
2002 ist er gelauncht. So, ach ja, siehst du mal hier, Opera hatte ja auch noch die EE-Engine zeitweise drin. Die hatten ja noch nicht mal, also die hatten, was heißt noch nicht mal, aber die hatten nicht ihre eigene Engine, sondern haben auch die Internet Explorer Engine benutzt.
Also Engine im Sinne von Rendering, also Grafik.
Das, was das Dokument zusammenbaut, genau. So, und jetzt können wir mal einen Schnitt machen, weil jetzt geht es halt los irgendwie nicht irgendwie, also natürlich gibt es immer mehr Browser, aber dann gab es jetzt auch immer mehr Technologien, die in die Browser reinwanderten.
Dann lasst uns doch den Schnitt wieder folgendermaßen machen. Ich spiele eine Musik, wir machen nochmal ein kurzes Update in Sachen Fußball, was da gerade los ist, ob die alle feiern oder Spaß haben, was auch immer. Danach reden wir über weitere Dinge in Sachen Browsern im Chaos Radio. Teil 136, hier Fritz. Die Nummern bist du mittlerweile kennen, oder?
Nee, sag du mal an.
0331, 7097110. Es sah ja fast so aus, als ob wir in eine Verlängerung reinschlittern, aber dann in den wirklich allerletzten Sekunden schoss Philipp Lahm das 3 zu 2 und damit steht Deutschland im Finale der Fußball-Europameisterschaft auf der Fanmeile in Berlin am 17. Juni. Wo über 400.000 Leute sein sollen, ist er unser Reporter Philipp Berger. Hallo Philipp. Es war ja wirklich extrem knapp, es stand 2 zu 2 und Philipp Lahm schießt in den letzten Sekunden kurz vor der Verlängerung noch ein Tor. Wie war denn die Stimmung bei euch? Ja und da wir mit dem Wetter ja auch Glück gehabt haben, die Stimmung hier ist bombastisch gewesen.
Konkret stehe ich am großen Stern, am Kreisel, bei der Goldelse.
Hier strömen jetzt 10.000, naja du hast 400.000 insgesamt gesagt, das sieht ja noch den einen oder anderen Ausgang, aber hier wirklich tausende Leute laufen an mir vorbei, wenige Türken. Also eigentlich konkret nur Schwarz-Rot-Gold zu sehen.
Eine coole Aktion gab es hier auf der Fan-Malle. Da wurden so Schwarz-Rot-Gold-Iroquesen von oben, von den bevölkerten Wagen ins Publikum geworfen.
Jetzt haben alle Leute eine neue Frisur, die jetzt nach Hause gehen.
Die Stimmung absolut friedlich.
Die letzten fünf Minuten waren natürlich schweinepackend, als die Türken dann noch das 2.2. rein gedonnert haben.
Und da war die Stimmung ein bisschen am Boden, da wurde gepfiffen.
Dann fiel das Bild auch ein paar Mal noch aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die Störung...
Nee, wir hatten es auch, glaube ich, drei Bildausfälle.
Jaja, es gab immer mal wieder Bildausfälle. Also es gab gelnde Five-Konzerte, aber bis auf die üblichen Rangeneien, alles total friedlich.
Es hielten sich wildfremde Leute in den Armen, stießen an, knutschen sich, wickeln sich in die deutschen Fahnen ein.
Ich habe sogar Leute, die Nationalhymne singen können.
Aber wenn du hinter dir höhe Kranken wagen, und du hast gerade gesagt, die üblichen Rangeneien, ist es friedlich bei euch?
Ja, man hört natürlich Scherbengeklöre.
Es gibt auch Mörder, die durch die Wege geschossen werden, Rassismus, ich denke mal, bei 400.000 Besuchern, da ist ein bisschen Schwund ganz normal.
Aber es sind wirklich wenige Wagen mit Kranken, mit Laulich, die hier langfahren.
Ich glaube, das sind die üblichen Schwächeanfälle oder Alkoholvergiftungen.
Alle klar, wir fassen zusammen eine großartige Fußballparty in Basel, eine schicke Party in Berlin auf der Fanmeile. Philipp Berger, vielen Dank. Tschüss, und wenn was ist, meldest du dich, ne?
Ja, ich geh jetzt zum Kuhdamm und höre mir dann den Autokorso an.
Sag Bescheid, was am Kuhdamm ist, meld dich, wenn du da bist, dann hören wir gerne noch mal rein. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaos Radio Teil 136 mit Huckel mit Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen und mitzureden. Heute ist das Thema Browser. Wir haben schon angefangen ganz im Urschleimen, was macht ein Browser eigentlich? Wie kommt der Browser mit dem Server dazu, sich eine Webseite zu bauen? Dann hatte Huckel eben eine höchst interessante Exkursion in die Geschichte der Browser. Wir waren jetzt zum Schluss bei Mozilla und wollten jetzt eigentlich weitermachen im Text und Huckel. Hier ist deine Fläche.
Eigentlich kann man jetzt so ein bisschen schon fast anfangen.
Du merkst, mir ist das Stichwort entfallen.
Das waren die Browsertechnologien.
Technologie war das Wort, ganz genau.
Genau, also die ganzen Disco-Features mit irgendwie Web 2.0 und Interaktion.
Erstmal Web 1.0.
Erstmal Web 1.0? Okay, dann war's.
Ganz langsam. Ja, also irgendwie ein Stichwort haben wir noch vergessen zu erwähnen, das ist das W3C. Was heißt denn das ausgesprochen?
World Wide Web Konsortium, also W3 für dreimal W, World Wide Web Konsortium.
Ja, stimmt, genau. Ja, und die gab es auch schon relativ früh in der Geschichte des Webbs, und die waren eigentlich die, die sozusagen die Standards, die die Browser implementieren, um so eine Webseite anzuzeigen, vorgegeben haben. Internet Explorer haben wir schon gesagt, der war dann ein bisschen besser in der Implementation dieser Vorgaben. Netscape hat so gesagt, ach, nö, wir wollen jetzt irgendwie andere Sachen einbauen, das ist jetzt uns zu langweilig, was das W3C uns vorschlägt. Und da gab es sozusagen diese Schere. Und irgendwie, ab Firefox könnte man fast so sagen, ging es dann wieder darum, doch jetzt mal diese Webstandards enger zu verfolgen und sie richtig zu implementieren, weil, nämlich davor gab es ja auch noch die Phase, wo auf so einer Webseite immer stand, diese Seite kann am besten mit Internet Explorer, Internet Explorer angeschaut werden oder mit Netzgeb-Navigator, das daran lag, dass eben Netzgeb das implementiert hat, Internet Explorer, ein bisschen Standards, aber ein bisschen auch eigene Sachen. Und du konntest halt keine Seite für beide bauen oder nur unter extrem großem Aufwand. So und dann bei Firefox ging es halt darum, nicht nur Open Source, wir entwickeln zusammen Browser, sondern wir machen jetzt auch Webstandards, weil Webstandards sind gut. Wir kümmern uns jetzt mal darum, dass alle Seiten auf beiden Browsern oder auf allen Browsern gleich aussehen. So und dann ging es halt los. Dann als erstes hier Cascading Style Sheets, also was auch Mozilla schon konnte, aber dann bei Firefox auch erst so richtig wieder weiterverfolgt wurde. Das war sozusagen die erste große, neue Technologie, die dann dazu geführt hat, dass Webseiten auf einmal viel, viel hübscher aussehen. Also man erinnert sich ja auch echt mit grauen, also wenn man das Web Archive, kennst du übrigens das Web Archive? Ja genau, also die, die es nicht kennen, webarchive.org, da könnt ihr von eurer Lieblingsseite mal gucken, wie die 1995 so aussah.
Da könnt ihr mal gucken, wie fritz.de 1999 aussah, wirklich sehr anders.
Ich weiß doch noch, dass Fritz einfach ganz stolz darauf war, dass jetzt auch CSS machen und die Seite sah auch total bunt aus. Da gab es auch am Anfang...
Da gab es Preise dafür, wir haben Preise abgesandt dafür ohne Ende.
Dass die Seite so schön bunt ist.
Ja die war nicht nur bunt, da gab es großen Button, da stand drauf musste klicken und wenn man den klicken musste, wenn man musste klicken, musste klicken, dann kam man weiter, die war der Knaller.
Ja aber ich glaube man kann schon so sagen, dass also mit dem Firefox dann auch so eine neue Ära wieder eingeleitet wurde, also am Anfang haben alle versucht, sich möglichst abzusetzen und möglichst tolle viele eigene Sachen zu machen und irgendwie gab es dann auch so eine Trendwende, dass dann gesagt hat okay, wir wollen jetzt möglichst wieder standardkonform zu sein. Zumindestens beim oder auch beim Internet Explorer ist ja wenigstens ein bisschen auch zu beobachten, dass sie da auch wieder in die Richtung gehen.
Ja am Anfang waren sie da aber ganz sportlich dabei, also sie haben auch CSS 2.0, also die zweite Version des Standards, eigentlich gleich mitimplementiert. Ja und was halt da anders war so vorher, wie gesagt im Web-Archiv könnt ihr gucken, wie die Seiten früher aussahen, das war dann ohne CSS und mit CSS war es auf einmal irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht warum, aber wenn man mit CSS Webseiten gemacht hat, sahen die auf einmal schöner aus. Weil man sich vielleicht viel bewusster Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, wie man das jetzt gestalten möchte so, weil man irgendwie gesagt hat, ich parametrisiere jetzt meine Gestaltung in irgendwelchen Werten und irgendwie konnte man da viel schöner rumspielen, als jetzt im Editor mit What you see is, what you get irgendwie.
Der Wüsiwück, genau.
Ja irgendwie, man saß da damals im Editor und wollte dann ein Bild zentrieren oder sonst was und der Editor hat immer was anderes gemacht. Die Seite sah immer anders aus, als man sie eigentlich haben wollte. Und mit CSS hatte man dann wieder so mehr fein granulierte Kontrolle darüber, wie die Seite aussehen sollte. Und das haben echt auch viele zum Anlass genommen, so das Web erstmal wieder auf eine neue Stufe zu tragen. Nämlich erstens sahen die Seiten hübscher aus und zweitens war das halt mit diesen Standardkonformitäten irgendwie alles viel sauberer und aufgeräumter. Also es war irgendwie, das war ein großer Schritt, weil irgendwie sind auf einmal die Web-Designer aufgesprungen und haben irgendwie gesagt, ja, und jetzt geht's los.
Vor allem jetzt gibt's ja auch endlich mal was zu designen. Vorher war das ja alles, da konnte man halt irgendwie die Schrift grün machen und den Backen blau und so, aber so viel war da ja noch gar nicht. Wo kommt eigentlich das Cascading von Stylecheat her?
Naja, das ist im Prinzip, also XM oder XHTML oder HTML ist ja auch schon ineinander cascaded. Also es sind ja so Schachtelungen. Und dieses CSS macht im Prinzip, operiert ja auf diesen Verschachtelungen. Also du kannst halt nicht nur auf diesen verschachtelten Elementen deinen Style definieren, sondern du kannst halt auch, sagen wir mal, du machst eine Headline rot, ja, und in der Headline ist jetzt aber noch irgendwas anderes. Und dann kannst du sagen, ja, das da drin soll jetzt auch rot sein und es erbt so die Gestaltung von oben und von unten. Du kannst es ineinander stecken, also so ein bisschen verschachtelt.
Es sieht schicker aus.
Ja, du kannst einfach, du hast schon sehr große Möglichkeiten irgendwie mit bestimmten, ja wie soll man das sagen? Also im Prinzip funktioniert jetzt CSS so, man sagt irgendwie, das Element H4 soll jetzt grün sein. So und jetzt kann man eben nicht nur sagen, dass Element H4 ist, sondern man kann auch sagen, alle Elemente H4, die in einer Liste drin sind, die in einem Paragraph drin sind. Und dann verschachtelst du sozusagen deine Selektoren und Statements und kannst sie so ineinander mischen. Also es, ja, so würde ich jetzt dieses Cascading da drin erklären. Ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man auf Wikipedia nachguckt, noch irgendwie ein bisschen toller beschrieben, aber, ja.
Genau, und wenn ihr mal selber schauen wollt, bei eurer Lieblingswebseite, wie die aussieht, das sind in der Regel Dateien, die hinten auf.css enden für Cascading Style Sheets. Und diesen können aber auch im HTML-Qualitys in der Seite mit direkt eingebunden sein. Man kann auch diese Styles pro Element setzen. In der Regel ist es aber gerade bei komplexen Webseiten, ist es eben eine externe Datei, die dann von der Webseite mit eingebunden wird. Und, ja, dann zeigt die dahin. Die könnte aber auch einfach runterladen im Browser, die mir einfach die Datei-Namen oder sowas mit Copy-and-Paste in oben in die Adresszeile eingebt. Also nur mal so als Tipp, aber das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich eh schon.
So, und jetzt kann ich noch mal so ein bisschen von mir erzählen. Also ich war ja auch relativ früh online mit so Modem, Verlängerungskabel quer durchs Wohnzimmer gespannt und so weiter. Und im Internet-Sein war ja total der heiße Scheiß. Und natürlich habe ich auch My First Homepage gemacht, so auch mit so einem Visivic-Editor. Und danach, als das mit dem Browserkrieg losging und man sich nicht mehr darauf verlassen konnte, dass seine Seite in beiden Browsern gleich aussah, habe ich zum Beispiel ein bisschen Lust am Web verloren und habe dann eher so wieder klassische Print-Sachen gemacht. Bis dann halt in diese Cascading Style-Sheets kam mir irgendjemand mal gezeigt, guck mal, das muss jetzt alles gar nicht mehr so schlimm sein, das geht jetzt. Es gab auch so einen Punkt, wo Internet Explorer 6 und Firefox tatsächlich annähernd ähnliche Ergebnisse geliefert haben.
Wo man nicht mehr für jeden Browser eine separate Version basteln musste.
Genau, es gab so diese gefühlte Phase, wo das gleich war, sehr gleich stand. Und wie gesagt, wie ich gerade schon gemeint hab, da ging so das Web irgendwie so richtig nochmal ab. Dann haben irgendwie Leute, Gestalter, sich damit auseinandergesetzt und haben einfach verdammt hübsche und auch tolle Webseiten gemacht. Und das hat dafür gesorgt, dass irgendwie so große Firmen, vor allen Dingen große Firmen und sonst wer irgendwie gemeint haben, ja wir brauchen jetzt auch eine Webpräsenz, wir müssen da rein, das ist irgendwie total hip. Die Leute gehen da voll ab. Irgendwie, wir brauchen jetzt eine Webpräsenz. Und das war dann auch so die Zeit für New Economy 1.0. Irgendwie Pixel Park, vielleicht kennt ja der eine oder andere die Firma. Die haben dann so für eine Webpräsenz einfach Millionenbeträge aufgerufen. Ja, und das war halt so dieser erste große Schub im Web. Irgendwie jede Firma wollte da rein und wollte eine Webpräsenz und zeigen, wir sind modern, wir sind hip, wir können eine schöne Webseite machen und sie haben einfach Millionen verbrannt dafür. Das war für mich eigentlich Web 1.0. Alles davor war so, ja, für technisch Interessierte die Entwicklungsphase, möchte ich mal sagen.
Für die Nerd an sich und als solchen.
Ja, also genau. Also ich hatte nicht viele Freunde, die online waren. Also wenn ich irgendjemand erzählt habe, ich habe eine Homepage so 1996, so dann kann ich mir aber nicht angucken, ich habe kein Internet.
Ist schön, kommst du jetzt runter?
So war das dann schon. Und dann ist erstmal eine Zeit lang auch wieder nichts passiert. So dann war dieser Stand so. Und dann... Dann können wir so...
Flash kam denn irgendwann noch dazu, ne?
Oh ja, Flash werden war dabei ganz, ganz modern.
In unseren Aufzählungen vor der Sendung habe ich auch eine Sache vergessen, eine Web-Technologie, die schon ziemlich von Anfang an dabei war, die aber irgendwie keiner mehr auf dem Radar hat. Java. Kennt ihr euch erinnern, als Java rauskam, so Java Applets im Browser, das war doch das heißeste Seid geschnitten Brot, irgendwie die Idee, jetzt irgendwelche Java-Applikationen im Browser ausführen zu können. Also auf einer Webseite sogar, so irgendwie, was weiß ich, was gab es denn da, irgendwie irgendwelche simplen Demos gab es ja schon.
Also meistens haben die Leute nur irgendwelche dynamischen Menüs gemacht oder irgendwelche total sinnlosen Sachen auf der Webseite.
Du bist mit einer Maus über irgendein Menü und es wurde groß und klein und änderte die Farbe und so.
Ja, aber Java war tatsächlich recht früh dabei und das war irgendwie, als Java rauskam, war ja Ehenhype und dann irgendwie noch Applets in der Webseite. Krasses Zeug, aber heute benutzt es keine Sau.
Das war ja dennoch glaube ich einer der großen Killer für den Internet Explorer, weil die kein Java dabei hatten. Lizenzgründen damals noch.
Ich glaube, die mochten damals dann noch nicht so richtig. Also machen sie bis heute nicht. Flash. Genau, Flash war dann die nächste Sache und da fängt es jetzt so an, da geht es jetzt so in die Breite von Web-Technologien. Also wir hatten CSS für Aussehen machen und alles schick. Dann hatten wir JavaScript. Das gab es auch schon relativ früh. Zwar in unterschiedlichen Versionen in den jeweiligen Browsern, aber man konnte damit schon so Text blinken lassen und so Kleinigkeiten machen. So und dann kam noch dieses Flash hinzu. Und das war halt sozusagen wie so ein eigenes Programm im Browser nochmal drin. Weil das Flash hatte überhaupt nichts mit der HTML-Seite zu tun, außer dass es da drauf war. Aber um diesen Flash-Film abzuspielen oder anzuzeigen, war irgendwie komplett anderes Software eigentlich im Spiel. Nämlich dieses Flash-Plugin. So und da waren jetzt auf einmal wieder ganz andere Möglichkeiten gestimmt. Dann gab es nämlich die Phase, wo jeder seine Webseite in Flash gemacht hat.
Und die langsamen Internetverbindungen sind kollabiert, weil sie irgendwie bescheuerten Blinky-Blinky-Dinger laden mussten.
Genau, so und dann ging es halt los. So Flash, okay, dann können wir eine Grafik machen, die man so in HTML nicht machen konnte. Man konnte sie animieren. Ab einem bestimmten Punkt konnte man sie skripten. Also falls der eine oder andere das noch kennt, so Director von Macromedia war sozusagen der Vorläufer von Flash, könnte man sagen. Und da waren dann auf einmal ganz neue interaktive Konzepte möglich. Also das war auch so der Punkt, wo man dann tatsächlich so mit der Webseite so ein bisschen mehr noch interagieren konnte. Also irgendwie Buttons drücken ist das eine, aber so, ja, Animationen sehen, ausführen, auslösen, Sounds abspielen und solche Geschichten.
Ich glaube, das große Marketing-Argument war damals einfach, es sieht überall gleich aus, weil eben der Browser nicht mehr irgendwie das Entscheidende ist, sondern diese Software, die die Sachen anzeigt. Und auf der anderen Seite war es aber eben wieder so, dass Flash damals zumindest nur für Windows verfügbar war.
Mac auch.
Mac dann auch irgendwann, genau. Und aber natürlich die ganzen Unix-Systeme sind dann außen voll geblieben.
Genau, also das ist auch übrigens durchaus eine wichtige Entwicklung, dass so der Unix-Baum der Computerwelt einfach so einen Teil vom Internet gar nicht sehen konnte. So Flash-Plugins für Unix-Browser gab es einfach nicht. Gibt es bis heute nicht richtig. Also wenn auf dem Linux heutzutage Ubuntu irgendwie eine Seite mit Flash zum Beispiel, adobe.com ist ein gutes Beispiel, da liegt der Flash-Film immer über der Seite selber. Also du kannst nicht aufs Menü klicken, das HTML-Menü, weil das Flash einfach immer drüber liegt.
Du hast ein schönes Bild benutzt, du hast gesagt, die Hälfte der User kann ein Stückchen vom Internet gar nicht sehen. Die wissen gar nicht, dass es das gibt. Ein schönes Bild auf jeden Fall.
Die sind auf jeden Fall da, außen vor.
Wenn wir uns heute in einer Welt bewegen, ich will jetzt nicht zu weit vorgreifen, aber wo der Browser mehrere Unterschiede, also nicht nur eine Website anzeigen kann und Sachen animieren kann oder so, sondern mir gleichzeitig auch noch einen Wetterbericht gibt, automatisch also kleine Widgets mit einbauen kann und so. Wo geht denn das noch hin? Was wird denn der Browser irgendwann alles können? Gibt es da schon so einen Ausblick?
Vielleicht noch ein ganz kurzer Einwurf.
Was ist dir den Gedanken für nachher noch irgendwie aufgehört?
Es gab nämlich noch eine ganz bizare Technologie, die nennt sich Active Desktop. Ja, Active Desktop, genau, da erstmals eingeführt mit Windows 98. Wo man die Idee hatte, hey, HTML ist ja total toll. Und wir bauen jetzt mal diesen ganzen Desktop in HTML. Das heißt, meine ganzen Explorer-Fans, alles war dann irgendwie eine Webseite. Das war die Idee. Die ist man aber ziemlich schnell wieder von abgekommen, weil es irgendwie alles überhaupt nicht performt hat und langsam war. Und es war irgendwie mal so eine komische Unsitte, die damals irgendwie war. Und ich hab festgestellt gerade, dass teilweise immer noch Windows 2000 und Installationen, die es ja immer nochmal gibt, auch diesen Active Desktop irgendwie aktiviert haben. Den muss man dann ganz schnell erstmal deaktivieren, sonst ist das ganze System praktisch unbrauchbar, weil es irgendwie auch wahnsinnig Speicher frisst und letztendlich war es auch irgendwie eine riesige Sicherheitslücke, mehr oder weniger.
Ja, also war bei F95 tatsächlich schon als Feature verfügbar. Ja, okay, also Flash.
Wir können kurz eine Überlege-Musik spielen.
Lass uns doch mal eine Überlege-Musik spielen, also es gibt ja jetzt verschiedene Pfade, die wir beschreiten können. Hyperlinks folgen.
Welchen Weg werden die drei lustigen Herren von Chaosradio gehen? Bleiben sie dran. Chaosradio auf Fritz 0331 70 97 110. Everlast, Delon und Dalkon, Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Gab es gerade eine Anfrage, wie ist es eigentlich mit Leuten, die in der Schule jetzt immer noch Java lernen und sich damit beschäftigen? Ihr habt doch gerade gesagt, Java ist eigentlich total Web 1.0 und es braucht keiner mehr. Huckel, kannst du das mal gerade rücken?
Naja, also man benutzt halt Java nicht mehr, um Java Applets auf eine Seite zu tun, aber Java benutzt man sehr wohl, um sozusagen das, was auf einem Web-Server passiert, um so eine Webseite zu generieren. Da wird das sehr stark und viel und oft benutzt. Also große Anwendungen, Web-Anwendungen, die wirklich komplexe Sachverhalte abbilden und für große Firmen sind, die basieren hinter der Tür sozusagen auf Java und wirklich sehr weit verbreitet und das ist auch keine stehende Entwicklung. Das geht immer weiter und das kann überhaupt nicht schaden, sich da mit Java auszukennen, weil es gibt, genauso wie es für Frontend-Entwickler gibt, also für HTML und CSS und JavaScript, gibt es genauso einen großen Markt für Leute, die mit Java Web-Anwendungen entwickeln können.
Also wenn ihr gerade im Informatikkurs oder wo auch immer in der Schule Java lernt und gehofft habt, ihr könnt ab morgen sagen, wir kommen nicht mehr, weil es brauchen wir nicht mehr. Nichts ist, ihr müsst leider länger bleiben, aber ihr könnt es dann irgendwann auf jeden Fall noch benutzen.
Genau und wo wir gerade noch bei den Fragen sind, ich habe ja auch noch zwei Fragen per Mail bekommen, wo ich noch mal ganz kurz was zu sagen will. Das eine ist eine Frage nach den Randgruppen-Browsern, also diesen kleineren Sachen, kleinere Projekte, irgendwelche Ableger von den großen Browsern, ob wir da was zu sagen können, oder eben ganz neue. Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen schwierig. Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe so großartige Projekte von Rendering-Engines, also die Teile des Browsers sind die, die Darstellungen machen, außer jetzt den üblichen verdächtigen Webkit.
Naja, also es gibt die meisten kleineren Projekte, neben einfach die Open Source Engines von Firefox oder von Safari oder von Opera, falls die jetzt mittlerweile Open Source ist, und machen einfach nur eine eigene Oberfläche darüber und sparen vielleicht ein paar Features. Also ich würde da sagen, geht einfach auf die Wikipedia-Liste aller Web-Browser. Ich hatte die schon offen, die ist wirklich ellenlang, und da gibt es auch einen, also Vergleichs, Grafiken, lest euch das durch. Also ich persönlich benutze zum Beispiel Safari und Firefox in regelmäßigen Wechsel, und das reicht. Ich brauche jetzt nicht drei Gazillionen Browser, und die tun ihren Job gut genug für mich.
Aber im Endeffekt muss jeder selber entscheiden für die Anwendung, die ihr braucht, was ihr da habt, ausprobieren und dann sagen ja oder nie.
Genau, die andere Sache war noch eine Frage, das ist eigentlich fast ein bisschen was für später, aber ich mache es trotzdem, ich mache mal, wo wir schon dabei sind. Der Daniel hat nachgefragt, es gibt so Plug-Ins für den Browser, womit man zum Beispiel direkt von YouTube oder anderen Video-Webseiten direkt sozusagen die Videos runterrippen kann, also direkt von da runterladen kann. Und das wäre irgendwie in den AGBs nicht so vorgesehen, ob man sich da irgendwie strafbar macht. Das ist aber strafbar sowieso nicht im strafrechtlichen Sinne nach dem deutschen Recht, sondern es ist dann höchstens ein Verstoß gegen die AGBs. Aber wenn ihr die irgendwie gar nicht ordentlich akzeptiert habt oder so bestätigt habt mit dem Klick oder so, dann ist es eigentlich auch problemlos. Also das könnt ihr auf jeden Fall sorgenfrei benutzen.
Der letzte Stichpunkt in Sachen Technologie, wir haben ja über CSS und Java und Flash und so gesprochen, war auch Web 1.0, was ganz schön war, da kommt ein Garantiert jetzt Web 2.0.
Genau, das reißen wir eigentlich auch mal ganz kurz ab, weil das würde die Sendung problemlos noch füllen und das kann man...
Also Web 2.0, ganz kurz zusammengefasst, nicht nur der User kommuniziert, gibt Sachen in seinen Rechner ein, sondern es gibt eine Interaktion. Und MySpace verdient viel Geld und alle wollen das machen.
Naja, also der Gedanke bei Web 2.0 ist, also viele verbinden das mit technologischen Entwicklungen, nämlich diesem AJAX, diesen asynchronen Java-Skript, das können wir auch kurz nochmal ansprechen, aber eigentlich ist der Gedanke weg von einfach nur Webseiten, wo man irgendwie Informationen liest hin zu kollaborativen Webseiten, also Online-Communities, irgendwie wir sharen Sachen, wir tun unser Wissen ins Netz und wir machen das möglichst so gut, dass irgendwie das erstens maschinenlesbar ist, also dass es sozusagen auch in andere Webseiten ein Problem muss integriert werden kann, dass Programme das runterziehen können, verstehen können, damit die Suchmaschinen das parsen können und so weiter. Also das ist eher so das Web so semantisch zusammenweben. Ja, also irgendwie, wenn sich Google eine Seite anguckt, weiß es halt, okay, hier ist eine Überschrift, da ist ein Paragraph und so weiter. Das ist ja eh schon bekannt, aber das ist eben noch verknüpft mit, wir tun jetzt all unser Wissen rein, damit es auch irgendwas zum Suchen überhaupt gibt. Also Wikipedia ist erstens das beste Beispiel für Hypertext, also dieses klassische, wir verlinken Seiten und zum anderen eben gemeinsames Wissen einfach ins Netz zu tun.
Und auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass man nicht alles glauben sollte, was im Internet steht, weil nur wenn 5000 Leute sagen, Weihnachten ist am 28. August, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das wirklich stimmt.
Dafür gibt es ja Google Fight.
Wobei das mit dem semantischen Web, das geht ja eigentlich noch ein bisschen weiter. Also die Idee ist, dass man den Informationen jeweils eben noch diesen semantischen Kontext gibt und da sind wir glaube ich aber noch ein ganzes Stück weit von entfernt. Also dieses Querverlinken ist das eine, was bei Wikipedia passiert. Aber dieses eigentlich wirkliche, im wirklichen Sinne semantische Web, das ist glaube ich noch Zukunftsmusik. Und die Frage ist auch, ob da wirklich so ein echtes Interesse dran besteht, das zu machen, weil es einfach ein riesiger Aufwand wäre.
Aber diese Verstrickung findet schon krass statt. Also wenn du in deinem Blog was schreibst, das ist erstens eine Minute später schon bei Google. Also habe ich gestern erst wieder gehabt, Blogpost geschrieben, danach gegoogelt, war peng, sofort drin. Genauso irgendwie bei anderen Suchmaschinen. Also dieses, ich stelle eine Information ins Netz und die Information, als ich gerade was reingeschrieben habe, verteilt sich auf verschiedenste Orte und wird einfach irgendwo announced. Und irgendwelche Leute gucken halt drauf und irgendwo hast du Minuten später einen Kommentar im Blog. Das war einfach vorher nicht so. Also dieses vernetzte...
Wobei da sicherlich auch zu bedenken ist, dass die Internetzugänge wesentlich einfacher geworden sind und schneller geworden sind. Und es ist einfacher, an den unterschiedlichsten Orten online zu gehen. Du musst nicht mehr irgendwie nach Hause mit deinem Bruder einschalten und so, sondern du bist einfach online. Und dadurch kriegen es natürlich viele Leute viel schneller mit. Dadurch kommen die Comments schneller.
Aber es ist halt trotzdem irgendwie... Es wird halt überall aggregiert und bekannt gemacht. RSS und den ganzen Kram. Also wie gesagt, auch da ein Verweis einfach auf die Wikipedia Web 2.0. Da steht schon dieser semantische oder dieser dieser gemeinschaftliche Gedanke im Vordergrund. Und der wird auch durchaus getragen durch dieses AIACS. Das heißt, man klickt auf einen Link und kommt nicht zu einer anderen Seite, sondern im Hintergrund. Die Seite bleibt einfach auf dem Browser. Lädt der Browser so von irgendeinem Server neue Informationen und lädt die einfach in die bestehende Seite gerade mit rein.
Dynamisches HTML. Ist da auch eine...
Dynamisches HTML. Das heißt, früher wurde die Seite reingeladen und da war sie. Da ist nichts weiter mit passiert. Und jetzt lädst du eine Webseite und dann klickst du auf einen Link und auf einmal baut sich die Webseite um. Neue Elemente erscheinen, die Farbe ändert sich, was auch immer.
Genau, das ist eigentlich eine Errungenschaft, der von JavaScript, wo ich also entsprechend einen kleinen Programmcode in die Webseite einbauen kann, dass wenn dies und jenes passiert, dann soll sich die Seite in sich selbst verändern, also die Inhalte.
AJAX kommt auch von Microsoft, ne? Das ist auch tatsächlich... ActiveX irgendwie, dieses AJAX wurde von Microsoft erlacht und das haben dann... das war kein Web-Standard, das haben dann einfach die anderen Browser selber noch mitimplementiert und irgendwann wurde es dann Web-Standard.
Es gibt ja noch zwei große Stichworte, um die wir in dieser Sendung gerne noch rumsegeln würden. Das eine sind selbstverständlich die Sicherheitslücken, die immer wieder auftauchen, wenn es um die Frage geht, welchen Browser benutzt man jetzt und wenn alle Leute sagen, Internet Explorer ist böse, böse, böse, böse, böse. Und zum anderen geht es um Browser, Web-Browser basierte Anwendungen, die man also da mit dem Browser benutzen kann. Was wird in Zukunft mit dem Browser passieren? Was wird da alles möglich sein? Schaffen wir das jetzt noch in den gut drei Minuten vor Nachrichten oder wollen wir es nach Nachrichten machen?
Also zumindestens zu den Sicherheitslücken können wir mit einem Mythos aufräumen, nämlich dass Open Source Software generell sicher ist oder sicherer ist. Das ist glaube ich mal ein ganz ganz großer Mythos, weil diese Dinge einfach mittlerweile so komplex geworden sind, dass freiwillige Entwicklerteams, selbstwahrscheinlich bezahlte Entwicklerteams, nicht mal eben so die ganzen Sicherheitsprobleme überblicken können. Da entsteht einfach viel Kot und es ist völlig normal und auch jetzt nicht übermäßig verwerflich, dass es auch mal Sicherheitslücken gibt. Das Entscheidende ist, wie wird mit den Sicherheitslücken umgegangen und wie viele Leute gucken darauf. Und da ist es jetzt so eine Philosophiesache, ob man sagt, okay es ist eine macht eine Software sicherer, wenn da keiner außer dem Hersteller drauf guckt oder macht es eine Software sicherer, wenn da ganz viele Leute drauf gucken. Aber es eben nur dann bringt auch wirklich noch was, wenn wenn da Leute wirklich qualifiziert drauf gucken und dann auch entsprechende Sicherheitslücken melden.
Wie ist da deine persönliche Meinung dazu?
Naja, also ich finde es schon sympathisch, wenn man offen und ehrlich mit den Sachen umgeht, wenn dann einmal im Monat so ein großes Patchpaket kommt, sagt wir haben jetzt ein paar Sicherheitslücken beseitigt. Dann kann einerseits schön sein, andererseits beruhigend, andererseits finde ich es persönlich aber angenehmer, wenn ich weiß, ok, da ist ein Sicherheitsproblem. Ich kann, ich traue mir das zu zu beurteilen, ob das jetzt wirklich mich persönlich betrifft, wie ich mich möglicherweise verhalten kann, was ich tun kann, um den Browser sicher zu benutzen, bis das nächste Update da ist, bis die Sicherheitslücke behoben ist. Das ist aber wirklich so eine Sache, wie man seinen Computer benutzt und seine Software benutzt. Ob man sagt, das ist mir egal, macht das irgendwie ganz, oder ich habe jetzt den Anspruch, auch zu verstehen, was da so ungefähr passiert.
Also von der Geschwindigkeit, wie da Sicherheitslücken behoben werden, nehmen sie sich eigentlich auch nicht so richtig viel. Also auch Microsoft patcht schon relativ zeitnah die Sicherheitslücken. Also man kennt das ja vielleicht als Windows-Benutzer, dass da alle drei Tage irgendwie ein Internet Explorer-Sicherheitsupdate kommt. Und die Open Source Leute, die sind natürlich auch schnell dabei. Also da hat man jetzt nicht so einen Vorteil zwischen Open Source oder proprietären Software. Das ist einfach wirklich, ja, also bei Open Source hat man so als Computer-affiner Mensch eigentlich immer so ein besseres Gefühl. Die Jungs kämpfen da, wenn man gerade so ein bisschen die Web-Technologien kennt und weiß, was die da für Schmerzen auf sich nehmen, um die Welt ein bisschen besser zu machen mit einem tollen Browser, dann unterstützt man das schon eher. Die sind halt auch bei den Web-Standards in der Regel ein bisschen fleißiger dabei.
Also generell zu Sicherheitsproblemen beim Browser, ich glaube das größte Einfallstor ist wahrscheinlich ja das Skript und auch irgendwelche Plugins.
Ja, der User ist erstmal das größte Einfallstor. Weil der Browser kann noch so tolle Sicherheitsmaßnahmen haben, wenn du auf den falschen Link klickst, dann klickst du auf den falschen Link, dann kann der Browser nix machen.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch ganz unglückliche Kombinationen von Internet Explorer und Safari. Was war das für eine Geschichte, dass das Downloads automatisch auf dem Desktop abgelegt werden und die Internet Explorer auch noch gleich geöffnet werden? Nein, die geöffnet nicht, sondern der Internet Explorer lädt Dateien vom Desktop, wenn sie entsprechend angewiesen werden. Das war so eine ganz gruselige Kombination. Da ist es jetzt egal, ob das eine kommerzielle oder freie Software ist. Bei so einer unglücklichen Kombination kann einem das einfach dermaßen auf die Füße fallen. Damit muss ich als Anwender auch rechnen. Das heißt, wenn ich mit dem Computer das Internet benutze, egal ob ich da jetzt Web-Browser oder E-Mail oder was auch immer mache, ich muss einfach verdammt aufpassen, sobald das Internet im Spiel ist.
Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Das ist eine andere Geschichte, genau. Nach den Nachrichten wollen wir darüber sprechen über Anwendungen, die nicht mehr auf unserem PC installiert werden, sondern die dann im Browser laufen. Da gibt es so ganz tolle Sachen. Google hat irgendwie so eine ganze Office-Suite. Es gibt irgendwie Grafikprogramme, also Fotobearbeitung, Grafikprogramme. Was gibt es noch so Klassiker?
Alles möglich. Also ich könnte noch eine...
Das ist im weitesten Sinne die Variante, dass du von jedem Rechner der Welt arbeiten könntest, wenn du ein Passwort hast und dich auf eine Webseite einloggst und nicht mehr die Programme auf deiner Festplatte mit dir rumträgst.
Genau, da wollen wir mit euch auch darüber sprechen, ob ihr glaubt, dass das die Zukunft ist. Ob das der richtige Weg ist oder ob das alles Murks ist. Wie ist eure Erfahrung mit der Bedienung von solchen Sachen? Benutzt ihr so eine Software, findet ihr total toll? Was ist eure Empfehlung, was nicht? Und wie seht ihr, das ist der Weg der Zukunft? Oder glaubt ihr, dass es jetzt nur so ein kurzer Hype ist?
0331 70 97 110 Wenn diese Jungs ein ganz, ganz besonderes Konzert in Berlin geben, sind wir natürlich dabei.
Fritz präsentiert NERD, die MySpace Secret Show. NERD, NERD kommen am Freitag ab 21 Uhr im Roten Salon der Volksbühne Berlin, die MySpace Secret Show.
Und was ist daran jetzt noch secret?
Na jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr. Aber es heißt nun mal so. Fritz, Info, Nachrichten.
Finale. Oh, mit Matthias Sachow.
Deutschland steht im Finale der Fußball-Europameisterschaft. Das DFB-Team besiegte in Basel die Türkei mit 3 zu 2. Die Tore für Deutschland schossen Schweinsteiger und Klose. Und in der 90. Minute war es Philipp Lahm, der den Siegtreffer erzielte. Nach dem Spiel blieb es bislang ruhig in Berlin und Brandenburg. An Deutschlands größter Fan-Meile rund ums Brandenburger Tor in Berlin feierten 500.000 Fans friedlich. Weil der Kurfürstendamm mit einem Autokorso gerade vollständig überfüllt ist, hat die Polizei die Straße abgesperrt. Auch hier feiern türkische und deutsche Fans gemeinsam. Morgen Abend entscheidet sich im zweiten EM-Halbfinale, ob die Deutschen am Sonntag in Wien gegen Spanien oder Russland um den Titel spielen. Der Streit um die Wiederholung der Mathe-Prüfung für den mittleren Schulabschluss an Berliner Schulen geht weiter. Bildungssenator Zöllner legte inzwischen ein Gutachten eines Wissenschaftlers der Humboldt-Universität vor, wonach die Aufgaben nicht schwerer waren als bei der ersten Klausur. Der Vorsitzende des Landeselternausschusses Schindler widersprach dem Gutachten und berief sich auf andere Experten. Unabhängig vom Streit hat Zöllner die Kriterien für das Bestehen der Klausur herabgesetzt. Jetzt bestehen die Schüler die Klausur schon mit 45 statt mit 50 Prozent der Punkten. Die Bundesregierung will mehr gegen die wachsende Zahl übergewichtiger Menschen in Deutschland tun. Jetzt soll es einen bundesweiten Aktionsplan für gesunde Ernährung und mehr Bewegung geben. Mit Kampagnen in öffentlichen Einrichtungen sollen ernährungsbedingte Krankheiten vermieden werden. Auch die Lebensmittelindustrie soll ihren Beitrag leisten und freiwillig auf Süßwarenwerbung verzichten, die sich an Kinder unter 12 Jahren richtet. Die Verbraucherschutzorganisation Foodwatch kritisierte, die Pläne seien nicht ausreichend. Statt freiwilliger Vereinbarungen mit der Industrie müsse die Regierung verbindliche Regeln vorschreiben. Die Strafrechtsverschärfung für Neonazi-Kundgebungen ist verfassungsgemäß. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in einem Grundsatzurteil entschieden. Damit bestätigten die Richter das Verbot einer Kundgebung zum Todestag des Hitler-Stellvertreters Hess im bayerischen Bunnsiedel. Das dortige Landratsamt hatte 2005 eine geplante Veranstaltung verboten und sich dabei auf den verschärften Verfolgsverhetzungsparagrafen bezogen. Danach macht sich strafbar, wer öffentlich die Würde der NS-Opfer verletzt oder nationalsozialistische Gewalt- und Willkürherrschaft belässt. Machen wir erst das Wetter. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Neurupin 16 Grad, Cottbus, Wittenberge und Angermünde 18, Potsdam und Frankfurt 19 Grad und in Berlin 20 Grad momentan. In Richtung Lausitz gibt es heute Nacht noch gewittrigen Regen, der zieht später nach Osten ab. Die Temperaturen liegen nachts zwischen 12 und 16 Grad. Morgen ist es meist heiter. Später kommen von Westen her wieder mehr Wolken dazu. Es bleibt aber meist trocken bei maximal 26 Grad. Aber natürlich Stadtverkehr Berlin in der Innenstadt. Gibt es viele Behinderungen wegen des EM-Spiels Deutschland-Türkei. Wegen der Fan-Meile ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Brandenburger Tor und Großem Stern gesperrt. Außerdem geht auf dem Kuhdamm nichts mehr. Am besten das Auto stehen lassen und mit öffentlichen Fahren. Ansonsten, euch überall eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Wir sind im Chaos Radio Teil 136. Hockniss hier, Frank ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir freuen uns über eure Anrufe, falls ihr nicht irgendwo im Stau steht auf dem Kuhl am unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden nämlich über Browser. Wir hatten schon die Entwicklung vom Nichts zum Browser. Was macht der Browser mit dem Server, damit eine Website draus wird? Welche Technologien gibt es da? Und Frank ist eben ganz kurz auf die Sicherheitslücken eingegangen. Und natürlich müssen wir uns auf das kaprizieren, was mit dem Browser in Zukunft so möglich sein wird. Mit web-basierten Browser-Anwendungen. Richtig, das war das Stichwort, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Ich wollte noch eine kurze Geschichte zu diesen Sicherheitsgeschichten lesen. Also erzählen, nicht lesen. Und zwar mit diesen Communities, die wir auch kurz angesprochen hatten. Dann ging es ja dann auch so los, so bei Myspace oder anderen, könnte man dann seine eigene Profilseite machen. Das heißt, es war jetzt schon der Punkt, wo es zu kompliziert war, selber im Visivic-Editor eine Seite zusammen zu draggen. Und es war einfach viel einfacher, zu Myspace zu gehen und sagen hier, das bin ich, ich bin im Internet und das höre ich für Musik und das sind meine Freunde. So und dann haben die natürlich erlaubt, dass man seine Profilseite auch gestalterisch modifizieren kann. Und man konnte auch JavaScript einbinden. Und was dann so passiert ist, ist, dass findige Hacker mit diesem JavaScript auf der Seite, die Profildaten von anderen geklaut haben, also die Zugänge und die Profilseiten von anderen übernommen haben, mehr oder weniger. Natürlich hat sich dann MySpells gedacht, klar, dann verbieten wir jetzt JavaScript. Und dann ist aber folgendes passiert, es gibt im Internet Explorer, also im 6er war das glaube ich, gab es die Möglichkeit in einem Style Sheet JavaScript zu inkludieren über so eine HTC-Files, keine Ahnung. Und die haben einfach den gleichen Hack nochmal für alle Internet Explorer User gemacht, in dem sie einfach das Style Sheet genommen haben, um da das JavaScript zu inkludieren. Und das ist auch nochmal so diese Brücke zum Anfang und so, mitten drin. Du hast halt so viele Technologien und keiner kennt alle und es kann dann einfach passieren, du machst JavaScript aus und denkst dir, haha, jetzt ist alles sicher und dann findet jemand raus, dass Internet Explorer in seiner CSS-Implementation erlaubt nochmal JavaScript nachzuladen und du hast das gleiche Problem wieder. Ja, das nur so als Anekdote am Rande, also das ist Sicherheit im Netz, gibt es einfach nicht.
Vielleicht nochmal ein ganz kurzer Hinweis, weil es auch, also es ist hier auf der Mitmachseite vom Chaosradio erwähnt, unter wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de, dass Barrierefreiheit natürlich auch ein ganz ganz wichtiges Stichwort geworden ist, wo also mehr Behörden und wichtige Institutionen mittlerweile auch Internetauftritte haben und auch Dienste per Internet anbieten und da sind natürlich diese Style-Sheets auch ziemlich wertvoll, weil man einfach eine sehr einfache Basisversion der Webseite machen kann, die dann zum Beispiel auch mit so Braille-Lesegeräten ist, wo man dann die Schrift attasten kann oder man kann einfach auf bestimmte kontrastreiche Darstellungen umschalten und sowas geht natürlich besonders gut mit CSS. Insofern ist es also auch aus dem Aspekt schon mal eine wichtige Neuerung gewesen.
Ja, aber das ist genau dann auch semantisches Web. Wir räumen jetzt mal unseren HTML-Code auf, machen den mal bedeutungsvoller. Wir machen jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Table und da irgendwie einen Text rein und lassen ihn so aussehen wie eine Überschrift, aber in Wirklichkeit ist es gar keine, sondern wir benutzen so die HTML-Elemente, wie sie gedacht waren und damit dann eben auch auf einem Braille-Gerät das verwertet werden kann.
Okay, dann lass uns mal zu den Anwendungen kommen, weil wenn ich auf die Uhr gucke, wir haben noch eine Schalte zum Cooldump, wo ja gerade nichts geht. Wir haben also, sagen wir mal, über einen Daumen noch eine Viertelstunde.
Ja, also ich benutze keine Web-Anwendungen. Also es gibt ja da so, also ein ganz großer Anbieter von diesen Web-Anwendungen ist natürlich Google. Die haben irgendwie relativ früh angefangen, weiß nicht, war Gmail das erste, womit es so groß rausgegangen ist?
Also man muss ja bei Web-Anwendungen, gibt es eigentlich so eine Definition? Also ich meine, ist jetzt einfach mein GMX-Webmail-Dings oder generell irgendwie ein Web-Mail-Dings, ist es schon eine Web-Applikation oder fängt eine Web-Applikation erst dann an, wenn sie auch, sage ich mal, ohne Rückweg bei mir im Browser funktioniert, also ohne sozusagen, wenn ich quasi den Modem auflegen könnte, die Verbindung trennen könnte und erst wenn es darum geht, quasi irgendwas weiterzumachen, Text zu speichern oder so?
Naja, ich würde die Grenze so ziehen. Also im Prinzip ist es schon so, dass so ein Web-Mail so klassischer Art irgendwie auch eine Art Web-Applikation ist, aber es fängt irgendwie schon in dem Moment an, wo du so eigene Benutzer-Interfaces hast, die das erlauben, was normalerweise nur über Browser-Menüs oder über dein Betriebssystem möglich sind, also so Copy-and-Paste nochmal selber in der Web-Applikation drin, weißt du, wenn so eine Sache anfangen, dass du in der Webseite irgendwie bestimmte Tools zur Verfügung hast, mit denen du klicken, draggen und droppen und Kampen pasten kannst.
Dass man bei Google Text zum Beispiel einen Text schreiben kann, als ob man einen Text schreiben würde, aber du schreibst den nicht auf deinem Rechner, sondern auf einer Webseite.
Also da fängt für mich dann so richtig Web-Applikation eigentlich an. Auf der Wikiseite stand ja, es wäre gut, auf iOS einzugehen, das ist halt irgendwie, die implementieren auf einer Webseite sozusagen nochmal dein Betriebssystem Desktop nach. Also du hast dann irgendwie auch einen Home-Folder und einen Trash. Es ist irgendwie total unbenutzbar und du hast halt irgendwie kaum sinnvolle Programme da drauf, aber es ist irgendwie, ja, du hast dann einfach deinen Desktop nochmal im Browser.
Ist das auch so eine Geschichte, die jetzt noch in den Kinderschuhen steckt und wo alle versuchen, möglichst mitzumischen und später nicht hinten dran zu stehen?
Also ich werte das eher so als ausloten, was geht. Also gerade so diese Open Source, wir machen jetzt den Desktop im Webprojekt, ist eigentlich so, was geht alles im Web? Was kann ich mit den Technologien, die es jetzt wirklich im Browser gibt, alles machen? Und man stellt fest, verdammt viel.
Also es gibt ja die sogenannten thin-kleins, also schmale, dünne, klein, kleine PCs, Arbeitsplatz-PCs, dieses Konzept gibt es schon relativ lange und bisher liefen da denn irgendwelche entweder in der Unix-Welt, im Prinzip einfach nur irgendwelche Darstellungen für X-Windows-System, wo also die Applikation selbst auf einem entfernten Server lief, aber mein Gerät, quasi was ich unterm Schreibtisch hatte oder so, oder auf dem Schreibtisch zu stehen hatte, hat dann nur die Anzeige übernommen. Es hat also über das Netzwerk kommuniziert und da wurde quasi die Display-Anzeige, die Bildschirmanzeige wurde dann per Netz auf mein Gerät verlagert und die Eingabe entsprechend zurück übertragen. So ein bisschen ähnliches Konzept ist vielleicht bei diesen browserbasierten Anwendungen auch zu sehen. Das heißt, die Idee, ich habe einfach einen Client, wo ich keine Software installieren muss, wo ich nichts pflegen muss, sondern das Einzige, was da ist, da geht irgendwie das Ding fährt hoch und dann geht ein Browser auf und dann bin ich da.
Das ist halt auch zum Beispiel, also Flash ist ja die weitverbreitetste Web-Technologie überhaupt. Also es ist noch mehr deployed als Browser mit Javascript, mit eingeschalteten, also es gibt mehr Leute die, ja, also ich, kennst du jemanden ohne Flash, also die, abgesehen von den Linux-Usern. Ne, und deswegen ist das halt zum Beispiel auch so eine beliebte Plattform, eigentlich um Web-Applikationen zu bauen, aber...
Naja, bei Flash hast du halt wieder das Problem, es ist dann ein proprietäres System und es ist dann schon wieder vielleicht ein bisschen evil, sondern man will natürlich ein möglichst offen sein und vielleicht auch bei der Entwicklung her freies Software verwenden oder zumindest nicht auf einen Hersteller angewiesen sein.
Karma-Punkte sammeln.
Genau.
Ja, ok, jetzt können wir halt, wie gesagt, mal so, ja, ich weiß nicht, also wie gesagt, ich benutze das nicht so, ich benutze kein Google-Mail und ich benutze auch, ich editiere meine Fotos im Photoshop und ich stehe eher so auf Desktop-Applikationen. Es gab noch keine Web-Applikation, nämlich so richtig vom Hocker.
Jetzt müsste du eine Web-Applikation haben, die dich so wegbläst. Worauf wartest du denn?
Naja, eigentlich, äh, der Browser im Browser, haha.
Nee, also ich meine, es gibt jetzt, es gibt jetzt von Microsoft zum Beispiel ein neues Plugin, das heißt Silverlight, ja, da kannst du irgendwie mit Ruby, mit Python, mit irgendwie.NET Sprachen, also diesen, was weiß ich, was da alles dazugehört, Java bestimmt auch, oder? C-Sharp. Kannst halt irgendwie alle möglichen Programmiersprachen benutzen, um in deinem Browser in so einem extra Fenster oder in so einer Virtual Machine in dem Browser irgendwie Applikationen zu bauen. Das ist schon interessant, weil du da irgendwie mächtige Mittel in der Hand hast, um wirklich sinnvolle Applikationen zu bauen. Mail-Client habe ich auf der Platte, der funktioniert auch ziemlich gut. Also ich bin auch nicht so ein Typ, der ohne Notebook jetzt irgendwie im Internet-Café sitzt und Mail liest. Für so eine Leute ist das natürlich total toll. Oder jetzt Fotos bearbeiten, also irgendwie die Performance ist einfach schlecht, das ist langsam. Also Browser ist einfach eines der langsamsten Environments, um irgendwie überhaupt Sachen zu machen und da jetzt auch noch Bilder drin zu bearbeiten.
Ja, weil es im Endeffekt natürlich immer noch daran liegt, wie dick ist die Datenleitung, die da hinten reingeht.
Ja, nicht nur, also der Browser ist einfach sowieso langsam. Also jeder kleine Pixel, der sich ändert, verursacht, dass die ganze Seite neu gerendert wird. Und wie wir ja anfangs schon erklärt haben, ist das ziemlich teuer in der Rechenzeit. Und dadurch, also wenn du einen Pixel an und aus machst mit 25 Frames die Sekunde, dann ist deine CPU dicht. So ist 100% CPU-Last nur wegen einem Pixel. Und ja, das sagt eigentlich schon ziemlich viel über die Performance von Browsern. Und ja, für mich ist das nichts.
Also ich denke schon, dass es ein paar Anwendungen gibt, aber das sind dann mehr Anwendungen, die dann wirklich auch serverbasiert sind. Also klassischen Datenbank-Abfragen und so Geschichten, da macht es wahrscheinlich Sinn, die browserbasiert zu haben. Aber ich glaube so, also ein wirklicher Satz, also ich persönlich bin da skeptisch. Also mich würde auch interessieren, ob es einfach Leute gibt, die das nutzen. Und also ich persönlich kann mir das jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass das irgendwie die Technologie der Zukunft ist. Andererseits, vielleicht ist es auch eine Sache oder eine Tendenz, die wir auch ein bisschen dem Erfolg von Linux und dem Erfolg von Mac OS auch zu verdanken haben, dass nämlich einfach Windows nicht mehr die Softwareplattform ist. So, vorher war es ganz klar, Firma entwickelt Software für Windows. Punkt. So, keine Diskussion. So, und jetzt kommen aber mittlerweile halt doch mal so ein paar Mac-User und ein paar Linux-User. Hey, wie sieht es mit uns aus? Oder sagen die Unis, die sagen, ne, wir machen nur freie Software Linux oder Unix-basierten Sachen bei den Grafikern natürlich oder den ganzen Kreativen, wieder Mac sehr beliebt. Und sagen, wir hätten aber auch gerne irgendwie ein Office-Paket. Und so, und das da vielleicht so, vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr der Bedarf überhaupt da ist, wieder eine einheitliche Plattform zu haben. Und diese einheitliche Plattform, meint man, wäre jetzt ein Browser, oder?
Also im Endeffekt kann man sagen, da ist noch eine ganze Menge offen, da passiert noch eine ganze Menge in der Situation. Ich wollte noch ganz kurz anfügen, weil du hast ja gerade gesagt, ich würde interessieren, was die Leute da so haben wollen. Solltet ihr diese Sendung beispielsweise als Podcast hören, weil ihr heute schlant, schlant grölend auf dem Kuhnam steht, und dass ihr auf dem Stau rauskommt, könnt ihr euch natürlich auch gerne melden. Ihr schreibt eine Mail an mail-at ccc.de. Und wenn es da noch Anmerkungen gibt, dann können wir da irgendwie gerne noch in irgendeiner Form darauf eingehen. Wie ist das eigentlich mit, wir haben jetzt über viele verschiedene Browser gesprochen und die Entwicklung und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es so den ultimativen Browser, weil ich kann ja als Windows, also als PC-User, mir auch einen Safari ziehen, der eigentlich für einen Mac gedacht ist, und ich kann auf einen Mac mehr aber auch einen Firefox und einen Internet-Explorer ziehen und den da quasi benutzen. Es ist jetzt nicht mehr so, dass jedes einzelne System seinen speziellen Browser hat. Gibt es da so aus eurer Sicht die ultimative oder perfekte Maschine?
Du könntest schon mal sagen, welches nicht sind.
Also Internet-Explorer, wie ich ihn liebevoll nenne, ist natürlich irgendwie bei mir zumindest die allerletzte, weil es bereitet einem Web-Entwickler einfach konstant Schmerzen, eine Webseite zu bauen, die auf dem Internet-Explorer genauso aussieht wie auf dem Firefox oder dem Safari. Abgesehen davon gibt es auch Unterschiede zwischen Safari und Firefox. Wie gesagt, ich persönlich bin jetzt auf Firefox und Safari festgefahren. Ich benutze eigentlich kaum große Features von den Browsern, habe auch kaum Plugins installiert, außer an Adblocker. Ich benutze den hauptsächlich zum Brausen und zum Web-Entwicklern. Der Firefox hat zum Beispiel für Web-Entwickler ein paar mehr Features. Der Safari ist einfach ein bisschen schlanker und schneller. Wenn ich irgendwie brause, brause ich mit Safari. Wenn ich Web-Entwickle, nehme ich Firefox. So ist irgendwie bei mir die Aufteilung. Die können beide extrem viel. Die sind ganz weit vorne mit der Implementation von Standards und Features. Die sind mittlerweile auch einigermaßen stable. Und Firefox 3 fühlt sich jetzt auch zum Beispiel eigentlich ganz gut an. Also ich hatte bis jetzt noch keine Probleme. Ich höre jetzt immer so von anderen, dass der instabil wäre oder irgendwelche Sachen ausgehen.
Ich habe eher ein Problem, dass ich habe so eine RSS-Line oben im Browser und die aktualisiert sich seit einer Woche nicht. Das ist ein bisschen doof, wenn du echt denkst, du hast alle News mal da.
Aber darum, das ist auch so eine Sache, da bin ich irgendwie plugins. Das wäre auch ein bisschen skeptisch.
Also Flash vielleicht noch, aber das war es dann auch.
Also ich bin da relativ emotionslos auch ehrlich gesagt. Also ich habe für mich rausgefunden, Firefox und Safari, also die Engines darunter, das ist ja WebKit und Gecko. Die sind halt in vielen anderen Browsern auch drin. Sind einfach wahrscheinlich schon ziemlich weit verbreitet ja. Und Internet Explorer läuft auf Mac sowieso nicht. Habe ich nur in der VM, im Windows, wenn ich mal was testen muss. Und von daher gibt es da jetzt erstmal nichts anderes. Opera gibt es auch so ein paar Fans. Der ist auf jeden Fall auch nicht schlecht. Ist auch mit Standardzeit vorne, aber irgendwie hier in unseren Breitengraden nicht so populär.
Auf Mobiltelefonen, also wer ein Nokia-Telefon hatte, die neuere Serie, da sind ja irgendwie auch Browser drauf. Da ist sogar irgendwie in einem eingebauten, ist auch glaube ich ein Webkit-Renderer. Aber dafür ist der Rest von dem Ding irgendwie extrem schnarchend langsam und macht dann auch nicht wirklich Spaß.
Aber auf Mobiltelefonen hat man auch nicht so richtig die Wahl, welchen Browser. Also noch nicht.
Naja, Opera gibt es, Opera Mini. Und der ist zumindestens von einer Browsing Experience sozusagen, also von wie man das Ding benutzt, deutlich angenehmer als jetzt der eingebaute.
Gibt es jetzt irgendwelche Dinge, die wir ganz groß nicht besprochen haben, die wir jetzt noch reinmüssen, weil ansonsten würde ich das Schiff langsam in den Hafen steuern. Wir haben nämlich noch einen Kollegen auf dem Kuhdamm zu stehen, der da mitten im Irrsinn ist.
Ja, ich würde vielleicht nochmal kurz meine Lieblingsweb-Applikation oder die, die ich am tollsten finde, ist eigentlich Flickr. Weil Flickr, also das sind eigentlich auch sowieso die Web-Applikationen, die ich für sinnvoll achte, die dir eigentlich Möglichkeiten bieten, die du auf dem Desktop einfach nicht hast. Und das sind eben diese Verlinkungen, also dass du irgendwie andere Kontexte mit einbeziehen kannst. Du kannst halt ein Foto bei Flickr hochladen. Du kannst das auf einer Map positionieren und den Geokoordinaten geben. Das heißt, bei Google Earth, wenn du auf irgendwie die Position brauchst, kriegst du das Foto von mir von Flickr da rein geladen. Du kannst irgendwie Fotos ziemlich gut suchen, weil die halt gut getaggt sind. Die sind semantisch miteinander irgendwie verwoben und so weiter. Und irgendwie auch so dieses Business-Modell irgendwie. Du kannst einen Account gratis haben und Bilder hochladen. Und wenn du halt irgendwie unlimited space hast, dann zahlst du irgendwie 24 Dollar im Jahr. Voll okay. Und das ist wirklich eine ziemlich nützliche Web-Applikation. Und das ist so das, was ich eigentlich dann im Web als Applikation benutze. Die Features bieten, die es so auf dem Desktop nicht gibt. Ich kann in meinem iPhoto oder wo auch immer nicht sagen, ich positioniere das auf einer Karte und ich share das mit dem und so weiter und so fort. Also zum Beispiel auf Flickr, wenn ich da ein Foto hochlade, kann es einfach passieren, dass die Zeit mich fragt, ob sie das in ihrer Zeitung veröffentlicht. Das ist schon ein paar Mal passiert. Auch im Reiseführer ist ein Foto von mir drin. Du lätst ein Foto hoch, du kriegst ein paar Tage später eine Nachricht und können wir das veröffentlichen? Ja.
Aber bezahlst du dafür nicht, oder?
Doch es gibt auch Leute, die dafür bezahlen tatsächlich. Also sie fragen und manchmal bezahlen sie auch dafür. Das ist auch voll okay. Aber Flickr funktioniert einfach. In dem Sinne sehe ich eigentlich auch Web-Applikationen, die wirklich Sinn machen.
Chaos Radio 136 war das mit Huckel und mit Frank. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Das war eine sehr amüsante Sendung mit einigen neuen Dingen, die wir lernen konnten.
Wir haben den Fußball getrotzt.
Wir haben den Fußball getrotzt, wir haben das Spiel begleitet. Wir hatten ein paar Anrufer und wir hatten auch eine Menge Fragen, die hier noch per Mail reinkamen. Ihr könnt wie gesagt die Sendung gerne nochmal hören. Gibt es als Podcast, könnt ihr euch ziehen. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist The Lost Website Lost. Wir hören uns wieder in vier Wochen im Ende Juli. Chaos Radio am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Euch beiden herzlichen Dank. Den letzten Song, den kriegt Huckel, den hat er sich ausgesucht. Mister Bob Dylan, The Man in Me.